programming throwdown episode 79 technical arguments take it away jason hey everybody so this is going to be an interesting episode. You know, we do every episode in one take, and this is going to be no exception. But this is going to have, it's going to be a pretty wild one. So, you know, usually we're covering a language, we're interviewing somebody, and, you know, we've talked to them beforehand. So we kind of know, you know, they're a subject matter in X and we know we know X pretty well This is gonna be something pretty different. We're gonna talk about arguing You know not in general although that might come up like more like I guess philosophical stuff But but really about arguing at work. We've both been in tech for a while Seen a lot of the canonical arguments. We'll kind of go through a lot of them
programming throwdown episode 79 technical arguments take it away jason hey everybody so this is going to be an interesting episode. You know, we do every episode in one take, and this is going to be no exception. But this is going to have, it's going to be a pretty wild one. So, you know, usually we're covering a language, we're interviewing somebody, and, you know, we've talked to them beforehand. So we kind of know, you know, they're a subject matter in X and we know we know X pretty well This is gonna be something pretty different. We're gonna talk about arguing You know not in general although that might come up like more like I guess philosophical stuff But but really about arguing at work. We've both been in tech for a while Seen a lot of the canonical arguments. We'll kind of go through a lot of them|||Programming Throwdown 第 79 期：技术争论，杰森，请开始吧。大家好，所以这将是一期很有意思的节目。你知道的，我们每期节目都是一气呵成，这次也不例外。但这一期会非常疯狂。通常情况下，我们会讨论一门语言，采访某个人，而且你知道的，我们之前和他们交流过。所以我们大概知道，他们是某个领域的专家，我们对那个领域也相当了解。而这次将会有所不同。我们要讨论的是争论，当然不是泛泛而谈的争论——尽管这可能会涉及到，更像是某种哲学层面的东西——而是真正关于工作中的争论。我们俩在科技界都待了一段时间，见过很多经典的争论。我们会逐一探讨其中的许多内容。
But I want to talk about blockchain. I actually took the time to really understand how blockchain works. So I'll spend a couple of minutes on that, like the actual technology. And Patrick, you can kind of fact check me on this. But basically, you know, when we did the blockchain episode with Amy Wan a while back, I had just started learning about blockchain. And one of the things I asked was sort of how do you keep somebody from just saying, oh, everyone gave me a million dollars, right? And what I learned is under the hood, there's this thing called basically a hash list. I think it's also called a Merkle tree or whatever, but the important takeaway is, you know, in this chain of events, every chain has the hash of the block before it.
But I want to talk about blockchain. I actually took the time to really understand how blockchain works. So I'll spend a couple of minutes on that, like the actual technology. And Patrick, you can kind of fact check me on this. But basically, you know, when we did the blockchain episode with Amy Wan a while back, I had just started learning about blockchain. And one of the things I asked was sort of how do you keep somebody from just saying, oh, everyone gave me a million dollars, right? And what I learned is under the hood, there's this thing called basically a hash list. I think it's also called a Merkle tree or whatever, but the important takeaway is, you know, in this chain of events, every chain has the hash of the block before it.|||但我先想聊聊区块链。我实际上花时间真正去理解了区块链是如何运作的。所以我花几分钟时间讲讲这个，也就是实际的技术。帕特里克，你可以在这方面帮我核实一下。基本上，你知道的，前段时间我们和艾米·万（Amy Wan）一起做区块链那一期节目时，我才刚开始了解区块链。我当时问的一个问题是，你如何防止某个人直接说“哦，每个人都给了我一百万美元”？我了解到的是，在底层有一个基本上叫哈希列表的东西。我想它也被称为默克尔树（Merkle tree）之类的，但重要的结论是，在这个事件链中，每一个链都包含着它前一个区块的哈希值。
And so what that means is, you know, you take that, let's say you're at block n and you have to make block n plus one. Well, block n plus one will have a hash of block n in it as part of the block. And so, but then if you think about it, it becomes this sort of recursive thing because block n has a hash of n minus one and n minus one has a hash of n minus two, so on and so on so on so forth so let's say you decide to change block you know two and give yourself a million dollars right for you to do that you have to change all the blocks afterwards right like you have to change everything because as soon as you change something um you know then the hash of the thing after that is different and that hash is part of the next hash and so it just it ends up being this huge thing
And so what that means is, you know, you take that, let's say you're at block n and you have to make block n plus one. Well, block n plus one will have a hash of block n in it as part of the block. And so, but then if you think about it, it becomes this sort of recursive thing because block n has a hash of n minus one and n minus one has a hash of n minus two, so on and so on so on so forth so let's say you decide to change block you know two and give yourself a million dollars right for you to do that you have to change all the blocks afterwards right like you have to change everything because as soon as you change something um you know then the hash of the thing after that is different and that hash is part of the next hash and so it just it ends up being this huge thing|||所以这意味着什么呢，比方说你处于第 n 个区块，你必须生成第 n+1 个区块。那么，第 n+1 个区块中将包含第 n 个区块的哈希值，作为区块的一部分。因此，如果你仔细想想，这就变成了一种递归的东西，因为第 n 个区块包含第 n-1 个区块的哈希值，而第 n-1 个区块包含第 n-2 个区块的哈希值，以此类推，没完没了。所以，假设你决定修改第 2 个区块，给自己一百万美元，对吧？为了做到这一点，你必须修改之后的所有区块，也就是说你必须修改所有东西，因为一旦你修改了某个东西，嗯，那么紧随其后的那个东西的哈希值就会改变，而这个哈希值又是下一个哈希值的一部分，所以它最终会变成一件极其庞大的工程。
that you have to change um and and and doing that change like adding a block is is hard right i mean i won't go into a lot of details but it's something that will take your computer a long time and so you know people are constantly adding these blocks the change getting longer and longer there's a ton of machines out there, and basically you just can't really keep up and you can't just make a change in the middle without progressing all the way forward to the present. And you can't really catch up to the present by yourself. So for this reason, this is sort of how the system kind of heals itself. If I go and even if I can, there's a whole bunch of things around how to mine go and even if I can,
that you have to change um and and and doing that change like adding a block is is hard right i mean i won't go into a lot of details but it's something that will take your computer a long time and so you know people are constantly adding these blocks the change getting longer and longer there's a ton of machines out there, and basically you just can't really keep up and you can't just make a change in the middle without progressing all the way forward to the present. And you can't really catch up to the present by yourself. So for this reason, this is sort of how the system kind of heals itself. If I go and even if I can, there's a whole bunch of things around how to mine go and even if I can,|||你需要去修改它。而且，进行这种修改——比如添加一个区块——是非常困难的。我的意思是，我不打算深入探讨太多细节，但这需要你的电脑花费很长时间。所以，你知道的，人们在不断地添加这些区块，这个链变得越来越长。外面有大量的机器，基本上你根本无法跟上，你也不能在中间做任何修改，除非一路推进到现在。而且你单凭自己也无法追赶到现在的进度。因此，出于这个原因，这正是系统自我修复的一种方式。如果我去……即使我能做到，周围还有一大堆关于如何挖矿的事情，即使我能……
there's a whole bunch of things around how to mine the block and all of that. But let's say I get super lucky and I can mine a block. You know, I can't say, oh, you know, everyone gave me a million dollars because, you know, other people aren't really going to validate that. And then while they're trying to reconcile all of that, more blocks are getting added and i'm not going to be able to to add blocks as quickly as everyone else can well the simple way to to state that though is you need people's identities are tied
there's a whole bunch of things around how to mine the block and all of that. But let's say I get super lucky and I can mine a block. You know, I can't say, oh, you know, everyone gave me a million dollars because, you know, other people aren't really going to validate that. And then while they're trying to reconcile all of that, more blocks are getting added and i'm not going to be able to to add blocks as quickly as everyone else can well the simple way to to state that though is you need people's identities are tied|||有关于如何挖矿以及所有诸如此类的繁杂事情。但假设我超级幸运，能够挖出一个区块。你知道的，我不能说，“哦，大家都给了我一百万美元”，因为其他人根本不会去验证这一点。然后，当他们试图核对所有这些东西时，会有更多的区块被添加进来，而我将无法像其他人那样快速地添加区块。不过，用简单的话来表述就是，你需要将人们的身份绑定在……
to a public key and you need a private key signing uh the transaction that that says you transferred a million dollars so if you mine a block and put all of these fraudulent records in, they wouldn't be cryptographically signed correctly. So you couldn't say Patrick gave me a million dollars because I'm the only one who has the private key that could sign such a message that you would include in your block. So if you made up one and put it in your block and then other people fact-checked you
to a public key and you need a private key signing uh the transaction that that says you transferred a million dollars so if you mine a block and put all of these fraudulent records in, they wouldn't be cryptographically signed correctly. So you couldn't say Patrick gave me a million dollars because I'm the only one who has the private key that could sign such a message that you would include in your block. So if you made up one and put it in your block and then other people fact-checked you|||公钥上，并且你需要一个私钥来对交易进行签名，该交易表明你转账了一百万美元。所以，如果你挖出一个区块并把所有这些虚假记录放进去，它们就不会被正确地进行密码学签名。因此你不能说“帕特里克给了我一百万美元”，因为我是唯一拥有私钥的人，只有这个私钥才能签署你要包含在区块中的这种消息。所以，如果你凭空捏造一个并放进你的区块中，然后其他人对你进行事实核查……
they would realize that that block was invalid yeah you're right that's true as well yeah um but then the uh and so then the merkle the tree the the chain comes in from the fact that someone else could mine on top of my fake block but they're disincentivized to do that because they won't get the reward if it's if the majority of nodes participating don't accept that as a valid path if they basically say hey somebody has an invalid block here and anything after that block is also invalid then right you're incentivized to make to sort of fact check other people so that if you complete your mining of a block you will emit a block which is on top of one that doesn't later get invalidated. Right. But then so yeah, I agree. There's the there's the public private key thing. But then you need more like you also need the
they would realize that that block was invalid yeah you're right that's true as well yeah um but then the uh and so then the merkle the tree the the chain comes in from the fact that someone else could mine on top of my fake block but they're disincentivized to do that because they won't get the reward if it's if the majority of nodes participating don't accept that as a valid path if they basically say hey somebody has an invalid block here and anything after that block is also invalid then right you're incentivized to make to sort of fact check other people so that if you complete your mining of a block you will emit a block which is on top of one that doesn't later get invalidated. Right. But then so yeah, I agree. There's the there's the public private key thing. But then you need more like you also need the|||他们就会意识到那个区块是无效的。是的，你说的对，这也是事实。嗯，不过随后……呃，所以默克尔树、这个链的机制就在于，别人可能会在我的假区块之上进行挖矿，但他们这样做是没有动力（激励）的，因为如果参与的大多数节点不接受那是一个有效路径，他们就不会获得奖励。如果他们基本上说：“嘿，这里有人有一个无效区块，该区块之后的任何内容也都是无效的”，那么，对吧？你就会被激励去对其他人进行事实核查，这样当你完成一个区块的挖矿时，你所发出的区块才会建立在另一个以后不会失效的区块之上。没错。不过话说回来，是的，我同意。这里有公钥私钥的问题。但除此之外，你还需要更多，比如你还需要……
proof of work and this whole like hash tree, because you could say, well, if I have the private public key, then what do I need all this other stuff for right and so so yeah i think you're right so let's say there's a list of sort of valid transactions right um at some point you still have to decide which sort of valid transactions you want to execute in the next block and that's where um you know if you limit it to the scope of valid transactions that's where the stuff i said originally right has an effect like like i can't just put all the blocks on myself and take all the credit for all those transactions because you know i'm having to solve this difficult problem and uh there's a whole bunch of other people doing it at the same time well the reason for
proof of work and this whole like hash tree, because you could say, well, if I have the private public key, then what do I need all this other stuff for right and so so yeah i think you're right so let's say there's a list of sort of valid transactions right um at some point you still have to decide which sort of valid transactions you want to execute in the next block and that's where um you know if you limit it to the scope of valid transactions that's where the stuff i said originally right has an effect like like i can't just put all the blocks on myself and take all the credit for all those transactions because you know i'm having to solve this difficult problem and uh there's a whole bunch of other people doing it at the same time well the reason for|||工作量证明以及整个这种哈希树，因为你可能会说，“好吧，如果我有了私钥公钥，那我还要所有这些其他东西干什么呢？”所以，是的，我认为你是对的。所以，假设有一个有效交易的列表，对吧？嗯，在某个时刻，你仍然必须决定要在下一个区块中执行哪种有效交易，这就是……你知道的，如果你把它限制在有效交易的范围内，那正是我最初所说的那种情况会发挥作用的地方——比如我不能把所有的区块都归为自己，并把所有这些交易的功劳都揽在自己身上，因为你知道的，我必须解决这个难题，而且还有一大群其他人同时也在这样做。嗯，之所以要有……
having the proof of work is is to say that that's exactly right like people are incentivized to sort of continue this chain on in a way that sort of adds credence to earlier things in the chain and they're incentivized to do that to do work and if it was if there wasn't a proof of work it would be too easy to just sort of make infinitely many of these things and and you would just get lost in the noise and so you see need some mechanism for sort of controlling the rate right yeah so it kind of makes sense i'll definitely read up uh maybe next month uh you know i'll post some links to the things that kind of explained it the best because i've read a bunch of them and uh you know obviously some are better than others but overall i was yeah it was really interesting it was a fascinating thing um you know i think i would love to see you know there
having the proof of work is is to say that that's exactly right like people are incentivized to sort of continue this chain on in a way that sort of adds credence to earlier things in the chain and they're incentivized to do that to do work and if it was if there wasn't a proof of work it would be too easy to just sort of make infinitely many of these things and and you would just get lost in the noise and so you see need some mechanism for sort of controlling the rate right yeah so it kind of makes sense i'll definitely read up uh maybe next month uh you know i'll post some links to the things that kind of explained it the best because i've read a bunch of them and uh you know obviously some are better than others but overall i was yeah it was really interesting it was a fascinating thing um you know i think i would love to see you know there|||工作量证明，正是为了说明这一点：人们受到激励去以某种方式延续这条链，这种方式为链中较早的内容增添了可信度，他们被激励去这样做、去做功。如果没有工作量证明，要无休止地制造出这些东西就会变得太容易了，而你只会迷失在噪音之中，所以你需要某种机制来控制速率，对吧？是的，所以这有点道理。我下个月一定抽空去读读——你知道的，我会把那些解释得最好的文章链接发出来，因为我读过很多这类的文章，而且显然有些写得比别的更好。但总的来说，是的，这真的很有趣，这是一件令人着迷的事情。嗯，我觉得我很想看到……你知道的，那里……
is some like i think it's called steamed but there's like a forum that's based on blockchain which i thought was pretty cool and uh it was a bunch of bunch of really neat stuff coming from that technology so your explanation of chain, also describes why you hear about cryptocurrency forks. So there's like Ethereum forked into Ethereum and Ethereum classic. Bitcoin has forked several times. And this is where people say you have if you had Bitcoin, now you have a Bitcoin and a Bitcoin cash token because there was a fork. And people talk about hard forks and soft forks. And those are basically paths where at some point in time, people say at block number n plus one, we're going to switch something in our code. And other people say we don't want to.
is some like i think it's called steamed but there's like a forum that's based on blockchain which i thought was pretty cool and uh it was a bunch of bunch of really neat stuff coming from that technology so your explanation of chain, also describes why you hear about cryptocurrency forks. So there's like Ethereum forked into Ethereum and Ethereum classic. Bitcoin has forked several times. And this is where people say you have if you had Bitcoin, now you have a Bitcoin and a Bitcoin cash token because there was a fork. And people talk about hard forks and soft forks. And those are basically paths where at some point in time, people say at block number n plus one, we're going to switch something in our code. And other people say we don't want to.|||有一个叫什么来着，好像叫 Steemit 吧，有一个基于区块链的论坛，我觉得挺酷的，而且从这项技术中诞生了许多非常棒的东西。所以你对链的解释，同时也说明了为什么你会听到加密货币“分叉”（fork）的说法。比如以太坊分叉成了以太坊（Ethereum）和以太坊经典（Ethereum Classic）。比特币也分叉了好几次。这就是人们所说的，如果你原本拥有比特币，现在你既有一个比特币，又有一个比特币现金（Bitcoin Cash）代币，因为发生了分叉。人们会谈论硬分叉（hard fork）和软分叉（soft fork）。这些基本上是这样的一些路径：在某个时间点，一些人说在第 n+1 个区块，我们要对代码进行某些更改，而另一些人则说我们不想改。
And there basically becomes a hard fork. There becomes two blocks minted with the same predecessor node. But then some group of people both authenticate those chains going forward. And so now you have two paths that were common at some point. So they diverge, they fork, and then they continue on. But from that point on, they don't always have the same sort of value relative to fiat for a cryptocurrency, or they have their own set of conditions that make or don't make sense so in the case of like ethereum versus ethereum classic whether the like dow the automated uh thing which had the hack whether that happened or not essentially in one they tried to undo that in the ethereum and in
And there basically becomes a hard fork. There becomes two blocks minted with the same predecessor node. But then some group of people both authenticate those chains going forward. And so now you have two paths that were common at some point. So they diverge, they fork, and then they continue on. But from that point on, they don't always have the same sort of value relative to fiat for a cryptocurrency, or they have their own set of conditions that make or don't make sense so in the case of like ethereum versus ethereum classic whether the like dow the automated uh thing which had the hack whether that happened or not essentially in one they tried to undo that in the ethereum and in|||于是基本上就出现了硬分叉。产生了两个由同一个前置节点铸造出来的区块。但随后，两群不同的人分别对这些延续下去的链进行身份验证。于是现在你有了两条在某个时间点曾是共同的路径。它们分道扬镳、分叉，然后各自继续前行。但从那时起，对于加密货币而言，它们相对于法定货币的价值并不总是相同的，或者它们有各自的一套合理或不合理的条件。所以在以太坊对阵以太坊经典（Ethereum Classic）的例子中，比如那个遭遇黑客攻击的自动化 DAO 组织事件，究竟有没有发生过——本质上，在以太坊中，他们试图撤销那个事件；而在……
the ethereum classic they said no that makes no sense to undo that i'm greatly simplifying so it makes no sense to undo that that was a valid thing happen. And so we're going to continue on saying as if it did happen. And so now the two chains diverge. They're hard forked from each other. So at some point, will one take over the other? Like, how does it? No, I mean, take over isn't the right. They can't because like you just described these chains.
the ethereum classic they said no that makes no sense to undo that i'm greatly simplifying so it makes no sense to undo that that was a valid thing happen. And so we're going to continue on saying as if it did happen. And so now the two chains diverge. They're hard forked from each other. So at some point, will one take over the other? Like, how does it? No, I mean, take over isn't the right. They can't because like you just described these chains.|||在以太坊经典中，他们说：“不，撤销这个毫无意义（我这是在大为简化），撤销它毫无意义，那是一件真实发生过的事。所以我们要继续下去，就好像它确实发生过一样。”于是现在这两条链分道扬镳了。它们彼此进行了硬分叉。那么在某个时刻，其中一个会取代另一个吗？就像，它是怎么……不，我的意思是，“取代”这个词不太对。它们不能，因为就像你刚才描述的这些链一样。
There's no mechanism for sort of joining them. But one could be worth more than the other. So like Ethereum is worth more relative to fiat relative to us dollars or euros than ethereum classic because more people think that that's the right choice i guess um okay but this has different implications of whether you're talking about a cryptocurrency on the blockchain or a different use um so so take but then takeover is anybody could you could create a fork of bitcoin if you wanted you could just come up with a new set of parameters mine do the proof
There's no mechanism for sort of joining them. But one could be worth more than the other. So like Ethereum is worth more relative to fiat relative to us dollars or euros than ethereum classic because more people think that that's the right choice i guess um okay but this has different implications of whether you're talking about a cryptocurrency on the blockchain or a different use um so so take but then takeover is anybody could you could create a fork of bitcoin if you wanted you could just come up with a new set of parameters mine do the proof|||根本没有机制能把它们合并起来。但其中一个的价值可能会比另一个高。所以，比如以太坊相对于法定货币（美元或欧元）的价值要比以太坊经典高，因为更多人认为那是正确的选择，我猜。嗯，好吧，但如果是讨论区块链上的加密货币还是其他不同的用途，这会有不同的含义。所以，至于“取代”……任何人都可以，如果你愿意的话，你可以创建一个比特币的分叉。你可以自己想出一套新的参数，去挖矿、做工作……
of work mine the coin and you know declare yay verily this is jason's jason coin as a fork of bitcoin um that's what i always but then you have to convince somebody it's worth something oh that's the hard part you have to convince somebody to's worth something. Oh, that's the hard part. You have to convince somebody to join on your chain, right? And start building on it and then accept it as valid trade from other people. Okay, that makes sense. But you could do that. And then I think the term soft fork is where basically something changes, but the entire consensus agrees and also moves along with the change oh okay so
of work mine the coin and you know declare yay verily this is jason's jason coin as a fork of bitcoin um that's what i always but then you have to convince somebody it's worth something oh that's the hard part you have to convince somebody to's worth something. Oh, that's the hard part. You have to convince somebody to join on your chain, right? And start building on it and then accept it as valid trade from other people. Okay, that makes sense. But you could do that. And then I think the term soft fork is where basically something changes, but the entire consensus agrees and also moves along with the change oh okay so|||量证明，挖出代币，然后你知道的，大声宣称：“哈利路亚，这就是杰森的‘杰森币’，作为比特币的一个分叉！”嗯，我总是……但随后你必须说服某人这东西有价值。哦，这才是最难的部分。你必须说服某人这东西有价值。哦，这才是最难的部分。你必须说服某人加入你的链，对吧？然后开始在上面构建，并接受它作为来自其他人的有效交易。好吧，这说得通。但你可以这么做。然后我认为“软分叉”这个词指的是，基本上某些东西改变了，但整个共识都表示赞同，并且也随着这一改变一并推进。哦，好吧，所以……
basically nobody bothers like mining the coins that would have been on the previous trajectory yeah so they're just they become worthless well just yeah just nobody ever bought there's no market for them yeah and so it's considered a soft fork versus a hard fork is some set of people agree to continue on to your chain oh i see oh it's interesting yeah that's wild but a soft fork happens every time i think basically every time you change some of like some parameter or an algorithm for how to do something yeah that makes sense because then some machines who don't have that change right will mine the wrong way and everyone else will mine it the right way is that right yes well right
basically nobody bothers like mining the coins that would have been on the previous trajectory yeah so they're just they become worthless well just yeah just nobody ever bought there's no market for them yeah and so it's considered a soft fork versus a hard fork is some set of people agree to continue on to your chain oh i see oh it's interesting yeah that's wild but a soft fork happens every time i think basically every time you change some of like some parameter or an algorithm for how to do something yeah that makes sense because then some machines who don't have that change right will mine the wrong way and everyone else will mine it the right way is that right yes well right|||基本上没有人再去费心去挖那些本会沿着先前轨迹产生的代币了。是的，所以它们……它们变得毫无价值。嗯，就是……是的，根本没有人买，也没有人给它们提供市场。是的，所以这就被视为软分叉，而硬分叉则是指某一部分人同意继续在你的链上走下去。哦，我明白了。哦，真有意思。是的，太疯狂了。但软分叉每次都会发生，我认为基本上每次你更改某些参数或某种做事算法时都会发生。是的，这说得通，因为那样的话，一些没有做出这种更改的机器就会用错误的方式挖矿，而其他所有人都会用正确的方式挖矿，是这样吗？是的。嗯，正确……
and wrong is perspective but the way that dominates yeah um the way that holds the value i guess all right on to news um this is pretty cool so this is open ai 5 um which is basically uh there's a game uh you know um alpha go played go better than, you know, the world champion. And so there's always been, you know, sort of the frontier of AI seems to be now, you know, playing these video games and basically passing the Turing test on these video games. And OpenAI 5 is sort of the next iteration or the next evolution of that. So there's a game called Defense of the Ancients 2. It's called Dota 2. And it's a five-on-five game.
and wrong is perspective but the way that dominates yeah um the way that holds the value i guess all right on to news um this is pretty cool so this is open ai 5 um which is basically uh there's a game uh you know um alpha go played go better than, you know, the world champion. And so there's always been, you know, sort of the frontier of AI seems to be now, you know, playing these video games and basically passing the Turing test on these video games. And OpenAI 5 is sort of the next iteration or the next evolution of that. So there's a game called Defense of the Ancients 2. It's called Dota 2. And it's a five-on-five game.|||和错误取决于你的视角，但占据主导地位的方式……是的，嗯，也就是那个保留了价值的方式，我猜。好吧，接下来进入新闻环节。嗯，这个非常酷。这就是 OpenAI Five。这基本上是……你知道有一个游戏，呃，AlphaGo 玩围棋比世界冠军还要厉害。因此，一直以来，人工智能的前沿领域似乎变成了玩这些电子游戏，并且基本上在这些电子游戏中通过图灵测试。而 OpenAI Five 就是这方面的下一个迭代或下一次进化。所以有一个游戏叫做《远古守卫 2》（Defense of the Ancients 2），也就是 Dota 2。这是一个 5 对 5 的游戏。
And so that presents a lot of really interesting challenges, right? So, you know, in theory, well, depending on the rules and what the AI is allowed to do, I mean, you could say, oh, let's have one brain for all five players, one AI for all five players. In a way, it's kind of cheating. But even beyond that, it turns out it's not very practical because that AI has to do exponentially more decisions. It's like, for example, just to keep it really simple, let's say you can go up, down, left, right, right?
And so that presents a lot of really interesting challenges, right? So, you, know, in theory, well, depending on the rules and what the AI is allowed to do, I mean, you could say, oh, let's have one brain for all five players, one AI for all five players. In a way, it's kind of cheating. But even beyond that, it turns out it's not very practical because that AI has to do exponentially more decisions. It's like, for example, just to keep it really simple, let's say you can go up, down, left, right, right?|||这带来了许多非常有趣的挑战，对吧？所以，理论上来说，嗯，这取决于规则以及允许人工智能做什么。我的意思是，你可以说：“哦，让我们为所有五个玩家设置同一个大脑，为所有五个玩家设置一个 AI。”从某种程度上说，这有点像作弊。但不仅于此，事实证明这其实不太现实，因为那个 AI 必须做出呈指数级增长更多的决策。就像，举个例子，为了保持简单，假设你可以向上、向下、向左、向右移动，对吧？
But let's say there's two players. Well, now I could go up and you could go up or I could go up and you could go up, down, left, right, right? But let's say there's two players. Well, now I could go up and you could go up, or I could go up and you could go left. So now there's 16 actions. It's not eight, it's 16, because all the combinations, right? And so making one AI for all the five players is not actually that good. So what they did is they actually created an AI that can communicate and send some signals to the other players, the other AI. Or it's really to itself because it's one sort of brain that's just been replicated five times. It's really interesting. There's a lot of technical detail.
But let's say there's two players. Well, now I could go up and you could go up or I could go up and you could go up, down, left, right, right? But let's say there's two players. Well, now I could go up and you could go up, or I could go up and you could go left. So now there's 16 actions. It's not eight, it's 16, because all the combinations, right? And so making one AI for all the five players is not actually that good. So what they did is they actually created an AI that can communicate and send some signals to the other players, the other AI. Or it's really to itself because it's one sort of brain that's just been replicated five times. It's really interesting. There's a lot of technical detail.|||但假设有两个玩家。那么现在我可以向上，你也可以向上，或者我可以向上，你也可以向上、向下、向左、向右……但假设有两个玩家。好吧，现在我可以向上，你也可以向上，或者我可以向上，你也可以向左。所以现在有 16 种动作。不是 8 种，而是 16 种，因为涵盖了所有的组合，对吧？因此，为所有五个玩家制作一个 AI 实际上并不是那么好。所以他们所做的是，他们实际上创造了一个能够与其他玩家（其他 AI）进行沟通并发送某些信号的 AI。或者说，其实是与它自己沟通，因为它是一种被复制了五份的“大脑”。这真的很有趣。这里面有很多技术细节。
So I'm kind of hand-waving a lot of that. But basically, it's really amazing. Also, they ran it on a ton of machines, so they really scaled it up. And they just have all these machines cranking through all these defensive ancient games. And they were able to beat some amateur human players. So, I mean, this isn't like world-class stuff yet or anything like that. But it's still good i mean um uh you know being able to beat an average an average human is is an amazing accomplishment and um
So I'm kind of hand-waving a lot of that. But basically, it's really amazing. Also, they ran it on a ton of machines, so they really scaled it up. And they just have all these machines cranking through all these defensive ancient games. And they were able to beat some amateur human players. So, I mean, this isn't like world-class stuff yet or anything like that. But it's still good i mean um uh you know being able to beat an average an average human is is an amazing accomplishment and um|||所以我把很多细节都一带而过了。但基本上，这真的很神奇。此外，他们在海量的机器上运行它，所以他们真正做到了规模化。他们只是让所有这些机器疯狂计算这些远古守卫游戏（Dota 2）。而且他们能够击败一些业余人类玩家。所以，我的意思是，这还不是世界级的水平或诸如此类的东西。但这依然很棒。我的意思是，呃，你知道的，能够击败一个普通人是一个了不起的成就，而且……
they also develop some pretty interesting you know kind of um like altruistic strategies you know so one of the one of the issues with ai is that it's very sort of self-centered and so you know one of the ways a lot of these systems would fall apart at least early on is that it's very sort of self-centered. And so, you know, one of the ways a lot of these systems would fall apart, at least early on, is that, you know, there wouldn't be sort of coordination and altruism. And if one person was in any amount of danger, they would just run away. And then the humans would just pick them off one by one. Now there's definitely some coordinated effort. There's players players you know the ai make sacrifices sometimes and things like that um it's pretty amazing i have to admit uh so i'm i'm in this field i mean this is what i do for a living and so i am really really shocked that uh um that
they also develop some pretty interesting you know kind of um like altruistic strategies you know so one of the one of the issues with ai is that it's very sort of self-centered and so you know one of the ways a lot of these systems would fall apart at least early on is that it's very sort of self-centered. And so, you know, one of the ways a lot of these systems would fall apart, at least early on, is that, you know, there wouldn't be sort of coordination and altruism. And if one person was in any amount of danger, they would just run away. And then the humans would just pick them off one by one. Now there's definitely some coordinated effort. There's players players you know the ai make sacrifices sometimes and things like that um it's pretty amazing i have to admit uh so i'm i'm in this field i mean this is what i do for a living and so i am really really shocked that uh um that|||他们还开发了一些非常有趣的、你知道的类似于利他主义的策略。你知道的，AI 的问题之一就是它非常以自我为中心。因此，你知道的，许多这类系统之所以会崩溃的原因之一（至少在早期是这样）就是它们太以自我为中心了。所以，你知道的，许多这类系统崩溃的方式之一，至少在早期，就是缺乏协调和利他主义。如果其中一个人遇到哪怕一点点危险，他们就会逃跑。然后人类就会把他们一个接一个地消灭掉。现在，确实存在一些协调一致的努力。有玩家……你知道的，AI 有时会做出牺牲诸如此类的事情。嗯，这相当惊人，我必须承认。呃，所以我……我身处这个领域，我的意思是，这就是我谋生的行业，所以我真的、真的很震惊，呃……
this much progress was made in this amount of time it's truly truly remarkable and so it's it's gonna be really really fascinating to see uh you know where this all goes and did they this you know this research they did in this paper obviously like is very difficult relative to like the amount of hidden information the number of choices to make where they find like any sort of what they thought was the reason to not continue to make even like not just beat amateurs but beat pros it's just like processing power algorithm. Like they give it. Yeah, that's a good question. I think so. Okay.
this much progress was made in this amount of time it's truly truly remarkable and so it's it's gonna be really really fascinating to see uh you know where this all goes and did they this you know this research they did in this paper obviously like is very difficult relative to like the amount of hidden information the number of choices to make where they find like any sort of what they thought was the reason to not continue to make even like not just beat amateurs but beat pros it's just like processing power algorithm. Like they give it. Yeah, that's a good question. I think so. Okay.|||能在这么短的时间内取得这么大的进步，这真的是非常了不起。所以，看到这一切将走向何方，将会非常非常引人入胜。而且他们——你知道的，他们在论文中所做的这项研究，显然与隐藏信息的数量、需要做出的选择数量相比是非常困难的——他们是否找到了任何他们认为不继续朝着“不仅能击败业余选手，还能击败职业选手”的方向前进的理由？这就像是处理能力或算法的问题吗？就像他们赋予它的……是的，这是个好问题。我想是的。好的。
I still don't think that they're the game. Theoretic part is being handled correctly. Right. So, so for example, if you look at, if you look at Dota, you know, the, the, the characters are stereotyped, right? So there's a carry who's supposed to carry the team, but basically they're the ones who are supposed to collect as much money as possible. You're not allowed to give money to your teammates, so they have to earn it.
I still don't think that they're the game. Theoretic part is being handled correctly. Right. So, so for example, if you look at, if you look at Dota, you know, the, the, the characters are stereotyped, right? So there's a carry who's supposed to carry the team, but basically they're the ones who are supposed to collect as much money as possible. You're not allowed to give money to your teammates, so they have to earn it.|||我仍然认为博弈论（game theory）部分没有得到正确的处理。没错。所以，举个例子，如果你看看 Dota，你知道的，角色是被脸谱化（定型）的，对吧？所以有一个“核心”（carry），本意是负责带飞团队，但基本上他们是那些应该尽可能多收集金钱的人。你不被允许把钱给队友，所以他们必须自己去挣。
But the goal is to make the carry earn as much money as possible and not the other players on your team. Then there's the support, and the support is responsible for for buying let's say all the items so so so the idea of altruism is baked into the character archetypes right and i think even in the model they they you know basically hand hand tune that right um and so then the the the real emergent altruism in in dota is this idea of like lane changing so for example uh for people who don't know dota real quick there's there's three little lanes like imagine like three little highways um all this battle this battle is sort of going on on these three highways and you're usually in one of them but you can spend some time to switch lanes and so
But the goal is to make the carry earn as much money as possible and not the other players on your team. Then there's the support, and the support is responsible for for buying let's say all the items so so so the idea of altruism is baked into the character archetypes right and i think even in the model they they you know basically hand hand tune that right um and so then the the the real emergent altruism in in dota is this idea of like lane changing so for example uh for people who don't know dota real quick there's there's three little lanes like imagine like three little highways all this battle this battle is sort of going on on these three highways and you're usually in one of them but you can spend some time to switch lanes and so|||但目标是让核心挣到尽可能多的钱，而不是让团队里的其他玩家挣。然后还有“辅助”（support），辅助负责购买所有的物品。所以，利他主义的理念其实已经融入了角色原型中，对吧？而且我认为甚至在模型中，他们——你知道的——基本上也是手工调优的。嗯，所以 Dota 中真正涌现出的利他主义，其实是“换线”这种概念。举个例子，对于那些不太了解 Dota 的人来说，简单讲，有三条小路——就像想象有三条小公路一样。所有的战斗都在这三条公路上进行，你通常身处其中一条，但你可以花一些时间去切换到别的线。所以……
for example let's say you're in the middle lane and the left lane uh there's a there's an enemy who's really weak in the left lane maybe he got hurt or something right you could try to go across to the left lane and and catch him um you know uh trap him and kill that that hero and then you get a lot of money um and so you know this there's this idea of like oh if if uh if the opponent is sort of beating up on me uh you know i'm gonna kind of take take some hits and things like that and let the opponent think he's sort of doing well meanwhile my teammates are switching lanes and all of a sudden there's going to be four people attacking this one guy. He hasn't really expected
for example let's say you're in the middle lane and the left lane uh there's a there's an enemy who's really weak in the left lane maybe he got hurt or something right you could try to go across to the left lane and and catch him um you know uh trap him and kill that that hero and then you get a lot of money and so you know this there's this idea of like oh if if uh if the opponent is sort of beating up on me uh you know i'm gonna kind of take take some hits and things like that and let the opponent think he's sort of doing well meanwhile my teammates are switching lanes and all of a sudden there's going to be four people attacking this one guy. He hasn't really expected|||比方说你在中路，而左路呢，呃，左路有一个非常弱的敌人，也许他受伤了什么的，对吧？你可以尝试穿行到左路去抓住他，嗯，呃，困住并击杀那个英雄，然后你就能获得很多钱。所以，你知道的，这就有一种想法，比如：“哦，如果……如果对手正在暴揍我，嗯，我要么挨上几下打击之类的事情，让对手觉得他打得挺好，与此同时我的队友正在换线，突然之间就会有四个人一起攻击这个家伙。”他其实并没有预料到这一点。
it. So, so there's sort of this like strategic, I guess I'll say strategic altruism or strategic coordination. That's something that AI does not do. Um, that is notably missing. And, and until they get that, um, it's, it's not going to be very good. So what I expect, if I was to predict the next thing that these folks would work on, I think they're going to really take a look at the game theoretic part of this. And they're going to try to do some kind of approximate Nash equilibrium or some opponent modeling or something like that so that at a high level, they can get this coordination, this altruism that they don't
it. So, so there's sort of this like strategic, I guess I'll say strategic altruism or strategic coordination. That's something that AI does not do. Um, that is notably missing. And, and until they get that, um, it's, it's not going to be very good. So what I expect, if I was to predict the next thing that these folks would work on, I think they're going to really take a look at the game theoretic part of this. And they're going to try to do some kind of approximate Nash equilibrium or some opponent modeling or something like that so that at a high level, they can get this coordination, this altruism that they don't|||所以，这存在某种战略上的——我想我称之为战略利他主义或战略协调。这是 AI 目前做不到的事情。嗯，这是明显缺失的。而且，在他们攻克这一点之前，嗯，它（AI 的表现）不会太好。所以我的期望是，如果要我预测这群人接下来会着手研究什么，我认为他们会真正去研究其中的博弈论部分。他们会尝试做某种近似的纳什均衡（Nash equilibrium）或某些对手建模（opponent modeling）之类的事情，以便在高层面上实现这种协调和利他主义，而这是他们目前所……
have at the moment. At a tactical level, they have it, which is really surprising, actually. I watched one video where this player kind of got behind the enemies and then kind of trapped them and the player who trapped them you know ended up like not really being able to get a lot done but because he trapped them you know the other players on his team were able to go in and kill them all and so that kind of like tactical coordination altruism they've been able to crack that which is a surprise but the strategic part they're still missing so yeah it's it's uh it's really really cool i mean i i wouldn't be surprised i mean i thought that this was way far out and now i'm starting to think that this could happen in the next like three four years the yeah robot overlords are coming we're all doing yeah that's right yeah
have at the moment. At a tactical level, they have it, which is really surprising, actually. I watched one video where this player kind of got behind the enemies and then kind of trapped them and the player who trapped them you know ended up like not really being able to get a lot done but because he trapped them you know the other players on his team were able to go in and kill them all and so that kind of like tactical coordination altruism they've been able to crack that which is a surprise but the strategic part they're still missing so yeah it's it's uh it's really really cool i mean i i wouldn't be surprised i mean i thought that this was way far out and now i'm starting to think that this could happen in the next like three four years the yeah robot overlords are coming we're all doing yeah that's right yeah|||不具备的。在战术层面，他们已经做到了，这其实非常令人惊讶。我看过一个视频，其中一个玩家绕到了敌人身后，然后把他们困住了，而那个负责困住敌人的玩家，你知道的，结果发现自己没能做成太多事情，但由于他困住了敌人，他团队里的其他玩家得以冲进去把他们全部击杀。所以这种战术层面的协调与利他主义，他们已经能够破解了，这很让人惊喜。但战略部分他们仍然有所欠缺。所以，是的，这……这真的、真的很酷。我的意思是，我一点也不会感到意外——我的意思是，我原本以为这还遥遥无期，而现在我开始觉得这可能在未来三、四年内就会发生。是的，机器人霸主要来了，我们都在……是的，没错，是的。
and then then they're going to take this ai and put it on the stock market and then okay microsoft announced this month that they're acquiring github uh that's wild yeah this was really surprising to me when i saw the news not because it just clearly seems sort of weird like microsoft buying github like why um but people pointed out like there are some you know decent reasons and and you know we'll see sort of what happens long term but uh you know microsoft is not the company that you know when i sort of i don't want to call it like coming of age when i was sort of went to college and first started working as a programmer everybody loved to hate on microsoft and i guess in retrospect they did make a lot of bad decisions around that time. But they've come a long way.
and then then they're going to take this ai and put it on the stock market and then okay microsoft announced this month that they're acquiring github uh that's wild yeah this was really surprising to me when i saw the news not because it just clearly seems sort of weird like microsoft buying github like why um but people pointed out like there are some you know decent reasons and and you know we'll see sort of what happens long term but uh you know microsoft is not the company that you know when i sort of i don't want to call it like coming of age when i was sort of went to college and first started working as a programmer everybody loved to hate on microsoft and i guess in retrospect they did make a lot of bad decisions around that time. But they've come a long way.|||然后接下来他们要把这个 AI 放到股市上去……好了，微软本月宣布收购 GitHub。呃，这太疯狂了。是的，当我看到这个消息时，真的非常震惊。倒不是因为它明显显得有点奇怪——比如微软为什么要买 GitHub？嗯——但人们指出，有一些，你知道的，还算充分的理由，而且你知道的，我们会看看长期来看会发生什么。但呃，你知道的，微软并不是那种……当我处于——我不想称之为成年，就是当我上大学并开始作为程序员工作时，每个人都喜欢痛恨微软。我想回过头来看，他们在那个时期确实做出了很多糟糕的决定。但他们已经取得了长足的进步。
And they really, you know, I've been looking through the list of things they've done recently. And they really have sort of seemed to kind of turn a page, which is pretty remarkable for a tech company to have been around as long as them and still be sort of in the running for, you know, impact on a day to day basis for people. Yeah, well well they replaced the CEO that was really when things turned around yeah and and the new guy I won't I'll mess up his name if I try to say I'll try I think Satya Nadella is that's pretty close all right sounds right to me um but he yeah so he does he's been doing a great job and you know they've they've bought github and continued to say like you know providing tools for job and you know, they've, they've bought GitHub and continue to say like, you know, providing tools for developers and, uh,
And they really, you know, I've been looking through the list of things they've done recently. And they really have sort of seemed to kind of turn a page, which is pretty remarkable for a tech company to have been around as long as them and still be sort of in the running for, you know, impact on a day to day basis for people. Yeah, well well they replaced the CEO that was really when things turned around yeah and and the new guy I won't I'll mess up his name if I try to say I'll try I think Satya Nadella is that's pretty close all right sounds right to me um but he yeah so he does he's been doing a great job and you know they've they've bought github and continued to say like you know providing tools for job and you know, they've, they've bought GitHub and continue to say like, you know, providing tools for developers and, uh,|||他们真的——你知道的，我一直在浏览他们最近所做的事情的清单。他们真的似乎已经翻开了新的一页，这对于一家像他们存在这么久、并且依然在人们日常生活中产生影响的科技公司来说，是非常了不起的。是的，嗯……嗯，他们更换了 CEO，那才是事情真正发生转折的时候。是的，而且新来的那个家伙——如果我尝试去念他的名字我会把它念砸的，但我可以试试——我想是萨蒂亚·纳德拉（Satya Nadella），差不多就是这样。好吧，听起来对的。嗯，但他……是的，所以他做得非常出色，而且你知道的，他们买下了 GitHub，并且继续表示，比如……你知道的，为开发者提供工具，呃……
and integrating and they do a lot of open source work. They contribute a lot to, I guess, to Linux stuff. People were even saying, um, and bringing that into windows as well. So, uh, you know, initial gut reaction is like, what? No. Oh. And there was some reports of, you know, projects fleeing GitHub and onto other things other things um to avoid whatever um another part of this that a lot of people don't talk about i'm kind of surprised is is you know github made atom the the yes id and um microsoft released the visual studio code which is a fork
and integrating and they do a lot of open source work. They contribute a lot to, I guess, to Linux stuff. People were even saying, um, and bringing that into windows as well. So, uh, you know, initial gut reaction is like, what? No. Oh. And there was some reports of, you know, projects fleeing GitHub and onto other things other things um to avoid whatever um another part of this that a lot of people don't talk about i'm kind of surprised is is you know github made atom the the yes id and um microsoft released the visual studio code which is a fork|||并且进行整合，他们做了很多开源工作。我猜他们对 Linux 相关的东西做出了很大贡献。人们甚至在说，嗯，还将这些引入到了 Windows 中。所以，呃，你知道的，最初的直觉反应是：“什么？不！噢。”而且有一些报道称，你知道的，有些项目正从 GitHub 逃离到其他东西上去，以避免任何可能的……嗯，这件事的另一个部分，很多人没有谈到，这让我有点惊讶，那就是你知道的，GitHub 制作了 Atom——那个 IDE，然后微软发布了 Visual Studio Code，它是 Atom 的一个分叉……
of atom and um and atom is unbelievably popular i, I bet Atom is really eating into their Visual Studio business to the point where they had to make Visual Studio Code. And so that's another thing is they really took a big IDE like off the table, you know, or at least they own it. So they turned it into a win-win. So they have announced that they believe that they are committed to maintaining both visual studio code and adam despite the fact that they're competing yeah i believe it so they came out later and did say they but yeah this is an interesting thing um i i don't have the the acquisition price i never know when they list acquisition prices if
of atom and um and atom is unbelievably popular i, I bet Atom is really eating into their Visual Studio business to the point where they had to make Visual Studio Code. And so that another thing is they really took a big IDE like off the table, you know, or at least they own it. So they turned it into a win-win. So they have announced that they believe that they are committed to maintaining both visual studio code and adam despite the fact that they're competing yeah i believe it so they came out later and did say they but yeah this is an interesting thing um i i don't have the the acquisition price i never know when they list acquisition prices if|||来自于 Atom，嗯，而且 Atom 极其受欢迎。我敢打赌，Atom 真的在侵蚀他们的 Visual Studio 业务，以至于他们不得不推出 Visual Studio Code。所以另一件事是，他们实际上把一个大型 IDE 从棋盘上拿掉了（收入囊中），你知道的，或者至少他们拥有了它。所以他们把它变成了一个双赢的局面。因此他们已经宣布，尽管存在竞争，他们仍然致力于同时维护 Visual Studio Code 和 Atom。是的，我相信。所以他们后来出来发表声明说他们会的。但，是的，这是一件有趣的事情。嗯，我没有……收购价格。每当他们列出收购价格时，我从来不知道……
those are i saw seven and a half billion i don't that's true i don't know how yeah how speculative versus real they are um i guess maybe they have to disclose because they're a publicly traded company um but yeah so the there's a high acquisition price and you know i hope it works well i like github i initially didn't really understand it or get it but but now i i like it and use it and we use it some for some peripheral projects I work on. And like the flow that they have for submitting code and reviewing code and managing projects has come a long way than when I had first was exposed to it. Yeah. So it's making improvements. And I know for open source projects, I mean, versus source versus source forge, which is what I used to know.
those are i saw seven and a half billion i don't that's true i don't know how yeah how speculative versus real they are um i guess maybe they have to disclose because they're a publicly traded company um but yeah so the there's a high acquisition price and you know i hope it works well i like github i initially didn't really understand it or get it but but now i i like it and use it and we use it some for some peripheral projects I work on. And like the flow that they have for submitting code and reviewing code and managing projects has come a long way than when I had first was exposed to it. Yeah. So it's making improvements. And I know for open source projects, I mean, versus source versus source forge, which is what I used to know.|||那些是真的。我看到的是 75 亿美元，我不知道那是真是假。我不知道……是的，它们有多少是猜测性的，有多少是真实的。嗯，我猜也许他们必须披露，因为他们是一家上市公司。嗯，但，是的，所以……收购价格很高，你知道的，我希望它运作良好。我喜欢 GitHub。我最初并不是真的很理解或懂它，但现在我很喜欢它并且经常使用它。我们做的一些周边项目也会用到它。而且他们提交代码、审查代码和管理项目的流程，比起我刚接触它的时候，已经取得了长足的进步。是的。所以它在不断改进。而且我知道对于开源项目来说，我的意思是，相比于 SourceForge——那是我以前知道的……
Yeah. Yeah. it seems to be you know crushing it so yeah i mean it's a very very solid product yeah it was pretty funny this idea like oh we're gonna leave i i don't feel threatened or i don't feel like my projects are threatened at all by this i mean i mean what what could they possibly do so i mean i guess some people didn't or people think about github as being you know just this bastion of open source and i guess it really is but they do a lot of closed source stuff as well and i mean i'm sure that's where all their money comes from is selling to companies for on-site licenses selling for companies to uh you know have private repositories um i mean that's their i don't even know if they
Yeah. Yeah. it seems to be you know crushing it so yeah i mean it's a very very solid product yeah it was pretty funny this idea like oh we're gonna leave i i don't feel threatened or i don't feel like my projects are threatened at all by this i mean i mean what what could they possibly do so i mean i guess some people didn't or people think about github as being you know just this bastion of open source and i guess it really is but they do a lot of closed source stuff as well and i mean i'm sure that's where all their money comes from is selling to companies for on-site licenses selling for companies to uh you know have private repositories um i mean that's their i don't even know if they|||平台，它似乎……你知道的，正在大获成功。所以，是的，我的意思是，这是一个非常、非常扎实的产品。是的，当时这种想法挺搞笑的，比如“哦，我们要离开了”。我一点也不觉得受到威胁，或者我觉得我的项目根本没有受到这事的威胁。我的意思是，他们究竟能做什么呢？所以，我想有些人没有——或者人们把 GitHub 视为开源的堡垒，我想它确实是，但他们也做了很多闭源的事情。我的意思是，我敢肯定这正是他们所有资金的来源——向企业出售本地部署许可证（on-site licenses），向企业出售私有代码库的使用权。嗯，我的意思是，那是他们的……我甚至不知道他们……
have donations for other stuff but i i mean they probably can't amount to much um so i'm sure they have a few really big companies that make a lot of money off of this and that's always been or they make all their money off of a few relatively large accounts is my guess that's typically how that stuff works out um and and my guess is that people never really thought about that because it happened sort of behind the scenes it wasn't the face of it but now and github was a startup you know they were a company um and now the fact that microsoft bought them though exposes you to this notion of wait but there is a company behind all this with profit motives and you know a desire to make, you know, product and sell it.
have donations for other stuff but i i mean they probably can't amount to much um so i'm sure they have a few really big companies that make a lot of money off of this and that's always been or they make all their money off of a few relatively large accounts is my guess that's typically how that stuff works out um and and my guess is that people never really thought about that because it happened sort of behind the scenes it wasn't the face of it but now and github was a startup you know they were a company um and now the fact that microsoft bought them though exposes you to this notion of wait but there is a company behind all this with profit motives and you know a desire to make, you know, product and sell it.|||是否接受其他东西的捐赠，但我的意思是，这些可能占不了多少。嗯，所以我确信他们有几个真正的大客户，从中赚取了巨额利润，而且情况一直如此——或者我猜他们所有的钱都是从几个相对较大的账户那里赚来的，这通常是这类事情的运作方式。嗯，而且我猜人们从未真正去思考过这一点，因为这有点发生在幕后，并不是它的光鲜表面。但现在，GitHub 曾经是一家初创公司，你知道的，他们是一家公司。嗯，而现在微软收购他们的事实，却将这样一个概念暴露在你面前：等等，这一切背后其实有一家带有盈利动机的公司，并且有着制造产品并将其出售的欲望。
And so most of the people I saw were recommending going to GitLab, where if I understand, GitLab actually does open source the hosting itself. Like you can run for free your own GitLab instance. Oh, I didn't know that. I believe that's the case. So they are also a company, but I believe it's more along the lines of traditional open source companies where they open source it and then they hope you sort of like, you know, contract them for hosting of the data or for, you know, support or adding features. But I don't quote me on that, but I believe it's more in line with that style of project versus. That makes sense.
And so most of the people I saw were recommending going to GitLab, where if I understand, GitLab actually does open source the hosting itself. Like you can run for free your own GitLab instance. Oh, I didn't know that. I believe that's the case. So they are also a company, but I believe it's more along the lines of traditional open source companies where they open source it and then they hope you sort of like, you know, contract them for hosting of the data or for, you, know, support or adding features. But I don't quote me on that, but I believe it's more in line with that style of project versus. That makes sense.|||因此，我看到的大多数人都建议转向 GitLab。据我了解，GitLab 实际上对托管服务本身进行了开源。就像你可以免费运行你自己的 GitLab 实例一样。哦，我不知道这个。我相信情况确实如此。所以他们也是一家公司，但我相信它更符合传统开源公司的路线，即他们将其开源，然后希望你——你知道的——雇佣他们来托管数据，或者获取支持、添加功能。不过不要原封不动地引用我的话，但我相信它更符合那种风格的项目。这说得通。
Or you need to integrate it with your like user system, and they charge you for that or something. Yeah. But GitHub itself was never really... It helped open source, but it wasn't itself open source. Yeah, that makes sense. Cool. My article is... This is a trick.
Or you need to integrate it with your like user system, and they charge you for that or something. Yeah. But GitHub itself was never really... It helped open source, but it wasn't itself open source. Yeah, that makes sense. Cool. My article is... This is a trick.|||或者你需要将它与你的用户系统集成，然后他们为此向你收费之类的。是的。但 GitHub 本身从来都不是真正的……它帮助了开源，但它本身并不是开源的。是的，这说得通。酷。我的文章是……这是一个圈套。
Families earning $117,000 a year now qualifies low income in California's Bay Area. So people probably know this. Patrick and I live in California's Bay Area. Obviously, I mean, there's like your gut reaction, which is, you know, that's that's that's crazy. But I actually want to talk a little bit about sort of like diffusing Silicon Valley, not diffusing as in like shutting down, but diffusing as in you would diffuse like water or something, right? So, you know, you're already starting to see it, but it's very slow. And yeah, I'd be really curious, Patrick, to hear what you think about, you know, I mean, a big part of Silicon Valley is communication over the internet, right? And so it seems like, you know, these big companies could at least move, you know,
Families earning $117,000 a year now qualifies low income in California's Bay Area. So people probably know this. Patrick and I live in California's Bay Area. Obviously, I mean, there's like your gut reaction, which is, you know, that's that's that's crazy. But I actually want to talk a little bit about sort of like diffusing Silicon Valley, not diffusing as in like shutting down, but diffusing as in you would diffuse like water or something, right? So, you know, you're already starting to see it, but it's very slow. And yeah, I'd be really curious, Patrick, to hear what you think about, you know, I mean, a big part of Silicon Valley is communication over the internet, right? And so it seems like, you know, these big companies could at least move, you know,|||在加州湾区，年收入 11.7 万美元的家庭现在符合低收入标准。所以大家可能都知道这一点。帕特里克和我住在加州湾区。显而易见，我的意思是，你的直觉反应是，你知道的，这太疯狂了。但我实际上想稍微谈谈关于“扩散”（diffusing）硅谷的话题——不是那种像倒闭关门一样的扩散，而是像你把水之类的东西扩散开来的那种扩散，对吧？所以，你知道的，你已经开始看到这种现象了，但进展非常缓慢。是的，帕特里克，我很想听听你的看法。你知道的，我的意思是，硅谷很大一部分是通过互联网进行沟通的，对吧？所以看起来，你知道的，这些大公司至少可以把……
branches of their organization to other cities and things like that. And, you know, that would fix or that would address this income issue, you know, traffic and all these other issues. But, you know, you never see it. Like you always kind of say, well, this is going to happen. You know, I always kind of expected it, but it it hasn't happened yet and so now i'm starting to think um that you
branches of their organization to other cities and things like that. And, you know, that would fix or that would address this income issue, you know, traffic and all these other issues. But, you, know, you never see it. Like you always kind of say, well, this is going to happen. You know, I always kind of expected it, but it it hasn't happened yet and so now i'm starting to think um that you|||他们组织的分支机构迁移到其他城市之类的。而且，你知道的，这会修复或解决这个收入问题、交通问题以及所有其他这些问题。但是，你知道的，你永远看不到这种情况发生。就像你总是会说：“嗯，这将会发生。”你知道的，我总是有点期待它发生，但它还没有发生。所以现在我开始认为，嗯……你……
know it's just maybe it's just there's something like magical i guess about being physically close that makes these uh companies all want to consolidate in one spot right yeah i mean eric schmidt from google uh i i mean i heard him talk once and someone you know mentioned this like why does google feel that it has to have everybody in the bay area living or coming to mountain view you know it's a tech company they make all their money on the internet like this makes no sense like why everybody in one location um and you know he didn't have really a great answer for it. But then they asked us, like, what about this cost of living?
know it's just maybe it's just there's something like magical i guess about being physically close that makes these uh companies all want to consolidate in one spot right yeah i mean eric schmidt from google uh i i mean i heard him talk someone you know mentioned this like why does google feel that it has to have everybody in the bay area living or coming to mountain view you know it's a tech company they make all their money on the internet like this makes no sense like why everybody in one location um and you know he didn't have really a great answer for it. But then they asked us, like, what about this cost of living?|||知道的，也许只是……我猜物理上靠得很近有一种某种神奇之处，使得这些大公司都想把资源整合在一个地方，对吧？是的，我的意思是，谷歌的前 CEO 埃里克·施密特（Eric Schmidt）——呃，我的意思是，我听过他演讲，有人提到过这一点：为什么谷歌觉得必须让所有人都住在湾区或者来山景城（Mountain View）上班？你知道的，这是一家科技公司，他们的钱都是通过互联网赚来的，这完全说不通啊，为什么所有人都要呆在同一个地方？嗯，而且你知道的，他并没有给出什么太好的答案。但随后他们问他，生活成本这个问题怎么办？
Like, this isn't sustainable. He's like, yeah, basically people have been saying that since, like, I want to say he said, like, the early 90s. I believe he came from, like, Sun Microsystems before going to Google. And so, like, he had been in that area for a long time. So I kind of expect he probably knows. But he's like, yeah, people have been saying that the Bay Area is overpriced and expensive and will never last for you know i guess three decades at least now um and they have gone through a couple boom bust cycles like obviously the dot-com crash
Like, this wasn't sustainable. He's like, yeah, basically people have been saying that since, like, I want to say he said, like, the early 90s. I believe he came from, like, Sun Microsystems before going to Google. And so, like, he had been in that area for a long time. So I kind of expect he probably knows. But he's like, yeah, people have been saying that the Bay Area is overpriced and expensive and will never last for you know i guess three decades at least now um and they have gone through a couple boom bust cycles like obviously the dot-com crash|||这根本不可持续。他说：“是的，基本上人们从——我想说他大概说的是 90 年代初就开始这么说了。”我相信他在去谷歌之前曾在 Sun Microsystems 工作过。所以，他在那个地区待了很长时间。因此我猜他大概是知道的。但他却说：“是的，人们一直都在说湾区物价虚高、极其昂贵、永远不会长久。”你知道的，我猜到现在至少有三十年了吧。而且他们经历了几次泡沫破裂的周期，比如显而易见的互联网泡沫破裂……
the 2008 housing crisis so although that that second one didn't really affect us if i recall correctly i didn't to the same degree. I mean, it did, but not in the same magnitude as a lot of other places. Yeah, I mean, I think it was like 20% versus other people were hit with like 50%. Yeah. So, I mean, there have been slight corrections. But in general, yeah, it's been just ever-increasing cost of living here. And as far as I know, and a lot of the articles around this mention this,
the 2008 housing crisis so although that that second one didn't really affect us if i recall correctly i didn't to the same degree. I mean, it did, but not in the same magnitude as a lot of other places. Yeah, I mean, I think it was like 20% versus other people were hit with like 50%. Yeah. So, I mean, there have been slight corrections. But in general, yeah, it's been just ever-increasing cost of living here. And as far as I know, and a lot of the articles around this mention this,|||2008 年的住房危机。所以尽管第二个危机并没有真正对我们产生影响（如果我没记错的话），至少没有达到那种程度。我的意思是，它确实产生了影响，但没有其他许多地方那么严重。我的意思是，我认为（跌幅）大概是 20%，而其他人则受到了 50% 左右的打击。是的。所以，我的意思是，虽然有过轻微的修正。但总的来说，是的，这里的生计成本一直在不断上涨。据我所知，关于这方面的许多文章也都提到了这一点……
which is an interesting observation if you don't live in this area. And as far as I know, and a lot of the articles around this mentioned this, it's, you know, which is an interesting observation if you don't live in this area. In general, in California, some things are more expensive, like gasoline is more expensive. But you also, in my experience, coming from not in California, I drive, I don't have to drive as far. Well, California as a whole, it's pretty big, but the Bay Area tends to be pretty compact relative to a lot of other areas. Not obviously living in a big city, but so you don't need to drive as far as you don't spend as much.
which is an interesting observation if you don't live in this area. And as far as I know, and a lot of the articles around this mentioned this, it's, you know, which is an interesting observation if you don't live in this area. In general, in California, some things are more expensive, like gasoline is more expensive. But you also, in my experience, coming from not in California, I drive, I don't have to drive as well. Well, California as a whole, it's pretty big, but the Bay Area tends to be pretty compact relative to a lot of other areas. Not obviously living in a big city, but so you don't need to drive as far as you don't spend as much.|||如果你不住在这个地区，这会是一个有趣的观察。据我所知，关于这方面的许多文章也都提到了这一点——也就是……如果你不住在这个地区，这会是一个有趣的观察。总的来说，在加州，有些东西更贵，比如汽油更贵。但根据我的经验，从加州以外的地方来的人会发现，我开车……我也不用开那么远的车。好吧，加州整体挺大的，但相对于其他许多地区，湾区往往相当紧凑。显然不是住在某个大城市里，但你不需要开那么远的车，所以花销也没有那么多。
So it's a little bit of a wash. But obviously there's a state tax that's pretty high. Not all states have taxes, but by far and away, the biggest thing is the actually housing cost. So housing is just really expensive. And the reason why you see something crazy like $117,000 a year, $117,000 per year could be considered, you know, low income is, is if you look, most people say you're not supposed to spend more than 40 or 50% of your income on housing. And if the median house, I believe I saw in San Francisco is now $900,000 for the median. Yeah.
So it's a little bit of a wash. But obviously there's a state tax that's pretty high. Not all states have taxes, but by far and away, the biggest thing is the actually housing cost. So housing is just really expensive. And the reason why you see something crazy like $117,000 a year, $117,000 per year could be considered, you know, low income is, is if you look, most people say you're not supposed to spend more than 40 or 50% of your income on housing. And if the median house, I believe I saw in San Francisco is now $900,000 for the median. Yeah.|||所以这有点功过相抵。但很明显，这里的州税相当高。并非所有州都有州税，但毫无疑问，最大的一块开支实际上是住房成本。所以住房确实非常昂贵。你之所以会看到年收入 11.7 万美元这样疯狂的数字——每年 11.7 万美元竟然可以被视为……你知道的……低收入，原因在于，如果你看一下，大多数人都说你不应该将收入的 40% 或 50% 以上用于住房。而如果中位数房屋——我相信我看到三藩市的中位数房价现在是 90 万美元。是的。
You know, if you sort of calculate out how much you're spending, you know, and rents are commiserate. If you look at how much you're spending, that's a large driver of that is strictly just housing. Right. Right. Yeah, I think. So, yeah, yeah, The housing is really large. But but, you know, the the Facebook and Apple and Google and Amazon and all these companies are building even more offices in the Bay Area. So it's pretty clear to me that that these companies see, you know, that the marginal value is still very very very high for having your employees local um and and i agree with you like no leader has really you know given like a good reason you know i have heard things like um they say that if you're um uh what was this oh i
You know, if you sort of calculate out how much you're spending, you know, and rents are commiserate. If you look at how much you're spending, that's a large driver of that is strictly just housing. Right. Right. Yeah, I think. So, yeah, yeah, The housing is really large. But but, you know, the the Facebook and Apple and Google and Amazon and all these companies are building even more offices in the Bay Area. So it's pretty clear to me that that these companies see, you know, that the marginal value is still very very very high for having your employees local um and and i agree with you like no leader has really you know given like a good reason you know i have heard things like um they say that if you're um uh what was this oh i|||你知道的，如果你算一下自己花了多少钱，你知道的，租金也是成比例的。如果你看看你花了多少钱，其中很大一部分推动力纯粹就是住房。没错。没错。是的，我想是的。所以，是的，是的，住房成本真的占比很大。但是，你知道的，Facebook、苹果、谷歌、亚马逊和所有这些公司正在湾区建造更多的办公室。所以对我来说很清楚，这些公司看到——你知道的——让员工留在本地的边际价值仍然非常、非常、非常高。嗯，而且我同意你的看法，没有哪个领导者真正——你知道的——给出了一个很好的理由。你知道，我听过这样的说法，比如……他们说，如果你是……呃……这是什么来着？哦，我……
don't know if this is that relevant but they they said that basically, if you're in a different, if you're more than I think 100 yards away, or if you're in another city, it's basically the same, like in terms of, you know, you don't walk over and talk to someone if they're in a building that's 100 yards away. There is a time zone issue that is very real um so so it may be the only way to expand is is vertically um like like portland seattle redding la san diego like um to eliminate the time zone but yeah i just i can't imagine that the personally i can't imagine that the the value of having your employees here is really as high as people are saying. But I'm also not leading 1,000 personal organizations. Neither am I. They clearly know something that we don't.
don't know if this is that relevant but they they said that basically, if you're in a different, if you're more than I think 100 yards away, or if you're in another city, it's basically the same, like in terms of, you know, you don't walk over and talk to someone if they're in a building that's 100 yards away. There is a time zone issue that is very real um so so may be the only way to expand is is vertically um like like portland seattle redding la san diego like um to eliminate the time zone but yeah i just i can n't imagine that the personally i can't imagine that the the value of having your employees here is really as high as people are saying. But I'm also not leading 1,000 personal organizations. Neither am I. They clearly know something that we don't.|||不知道这是否有多大关联，但他们说，基本上，如果你在另一个地方——如果你距离超过我猜 100 码，或者如果你在另一个城市，情况基本上是一样的——就……你知道的，如果有人在 100 码外的另一栋楼里，你根本不会走过去和他们说话。还有一个非常真实的“时区”问题。嗯，所以……也许唯一的扩张方式是垂直扩张，嗯，就像波特兰、西雅图、雷丁、洛杉矶、圣地亚哥那样，嗯……以消除时区差。但，是的，我只是……我无法想象，就我个人而言，我无法想象把员工留在本地的价值真的像人们说的那样高。但我也没有领导一个有一千名员工的组织。我也没有。他们显然知道一些我们不知道的事情。
I mean, I would love for some dispersing to happen. It would be great. Yeah, same here. But living here, being around all these people is a certain kind of interesting. And such a dense amount of tech people because you have a lot of concentration of people who like similar things to you uh so so there's a lot of catering to that which is nice um yeah i mean just to give it put it in perspective and i don't know if this story is really gonna do that but i'll tell it anyways i was with my son and he was sick
我的意思是，我很乐意看到一些分散发生。那会很棒。是的，我也是。但住在这里，身处这么多人中间有一种有趣的感觉。而且科技人才密度很高，因为有很多集中在一起、喜欢和你相似事物的人，所以有很多迎合这种需求的方面，这挺好的。嗯，是的，我是说，为了把它放在一个宏观视角来看——虽然我不知道这个故事是否真的能做到这一点，但我还是要讲一下——我和我儿子在一起，他生病了
so i took him to my wife was also sick so I took him to Safeway which is the grocery store that's open 24 hours and as we were leaving Safeway there was I think it was it wasn't necessarily like a bar but it was like a restaurant that had a bar basically if that makes it was a bar and so these gentlemen are walking out of the bar and I got a little bit nervous because really late at night these people were definitely like very intoxicated and um we had to walk right by them and as i walk right by them one of them basically tells like and i'm not gonna say it's a little bit rude i won't bother saying it but but basically told like a chess joke it was like some like lewd chess joke and i was like like this is like the dregs of society it's like it's like two drug drug people
所以我带他去——我妻子也病了——所以我带他去了Safeway，那是家24小时营业的杂货店。当我们离开Safeway时，我想，那不一定像是个酒吧，但基本上是个带酒吧的餐厅，如果这么说能说得通的话，总之它就是个酒吧。所以这些绅士正从酒吧里走出来，我有点紧张，因为在深夜，这些人显然非常醉，而且我们需要从他们旁边走过。当我从他们旁边走过时，其中一个人基本上说了一个——我不会说是有点粗鲁，我也懒得说是什么了——但基本上说了一个国际象棋的笑话。就像是什么下流的国际象棋笑话，当时我想，这简直是社会的残渣，就像是两个吸毒的人
telling like jokes about chess like at two in the morning but that's basically what it's like here it's just there's just it's it's uh it's it's it's crazy too when you talk to the other people on your team or at your company and it's like everyone was like soliditorian of their high school at some part of the world or something. It's just like mind boggling. Yeah. And I mean, I think for some, what do you call it?
在凌晨两点讲关于国际象棋的笑话，但这里差不多就是这样，这真的很疯狂。当你和团队里或公司里的其他人交谈时，也是这种感觉，每个人在世界的某个地方都曾是高中毕业生代表（致告别辞者）之类的人物。这简直太令人匪夷所思了。是的。而且我认为，对于某些……你把它叫什么？
Like table stakes, like for some companies, startups of certain nature and need certain kinds of people, you can only have it in this area or it makes the most sense to have it in this area and a lot of people argue about that i feel like that's an unknown yeah so i mean there's this
就像准入条件（table stakes）一样，对于某些公司、特定性质的初创企业以及需要特定类型人才的公司，你只能把它们放在这个区域，或者把它们放在这个区域最合乎逻辑，很多人对此争论不休，我觉得这是一个未知数。所以我的意思是，这里有
there's this unknown and no one wants to take the risk because it's so expensive what is it it's like no one got fired for choosing ibm is that was like it's the same thing it's like you're not going to get faulted i mean you might it might be wrong you might fail but nobody's really gonna like look at you twice if you say you're making a startup in the Bay Area. Yeah, exactly. But yeah, there's this question. You know, I have this sort of hypothetical like thought. Was it called a thought experiment? You know, if you opened a tech company in like pick the place in America, that's and I'm yeah, I'm not going to hypothesize. But imagine the close your eyes. Imagine the place in America that would be the worst for a tech company.
这里有一个未知数，没有人想承担风险，因为成本太高了。这是什么呢？就像“没有人因为选择IBM而被解雇”一样。就是这种感觉，你不会受到指责——当然你可能是错的，你可能会失败，但如果你说你在湾区创办了一家初创公司，没有人会用异样的眼光看你。是的，完全正确。但是，是的，这里有一个问题。你知道，我有一种假设性的想法。这叫思想实验吗？你知道，如果你在美利坚合众国的某个地方——由你来挑一个地方——开办一家科技公司，而且我，是的，我不会去做假设。但是想象一下，闭上眼睛。想象一下美国最不适合开办科技公司的那个地方。
Fargo. No, I don't know. Sorry if anyone's from Fargo. What's Fargo? Anyway, and let's assume Google opened a branch there. Well, some engineers are going to move from Mountain View to wherever that is. And that, I think think is an unknown quantity and and maybe when amazon finally builds this hq2 we'll be able to like at least get a measurement of that of that
法戈（Fargo）。不，我不知道。如果有来自法戈的朋友，请见谅。什么是法戈？不管怎样，让我们假设谷歌在那里开了一个分公司。好吧，一些工程师会从山景城搬到那个地方。我认为这是一个未知的变量，也许当亚马逊最终建成这个第二总部（HQ2）时，我们将能够至少对那个
number right but that's a different number than if you have a a startup and you're trying to build one in fargo yeah i feel like that's that's very different i mean because there are some engineers there but you're knows most of what i've seen has either been somewhere with a reasonable size tech scene and saying that's enough or we don't need the you know top 0.01 percent of the talent that exists in the bay area or um some something like that or they're just committing to being remote team so there exist people spread everywhere and if you're not committed to being remote team. So there exist people spread everywhere. And if you're not committed to this thing Jason said of having everybody within 100 yards of each other,
数字进行某种衡量，对吧？但那和你拥有一家初创公司并试图在法戈建立一家公司时的数字是不同的，是的，我觉得那是完全不同的。我是说，因为那里有一些工程师，但你知道，我见过的大多数情况要么是去一个科技氛围规模适中、并且觉得这就足够了的地方，要么就是我们不需要湾区现有的那前0.01%的顶级人才，或者诸如此类的情况，再或者他们就是致力于打造一个远程团队，所以员工分散在各地。如果你不致力于打造一个远程团队，所以员工分散在各地。如果你不致力于杰森刚才所说的让每个人都在彼此相距100码（约90米）以内的目标，
and you're already saying we're going to build a remote company, a remote team, your options open up dramatically. But if you say, hey, I need 30 really, really qualified people, and I want them to all sit within 100 yards, and I don't have to convince people to move, where am I going to go, you know, make my startup? Then your choices are much more limited. Yeah. I mean, I think with startups, there's a there's another challenge, which is most of the VCs are here and things like that. So for people to know, VCs venture capitalists. So those are
而你已经决定我们要建立一家远程公司、一个远程团队，你的选择就会大大增加。但如果你说，嘿，我需要30个非常、非常合格的人，而且我希望他们都坐在相距100码的范围内，并且我不需要说服人们搬家，那我该去哪里创立我的初创公司呢？那么你的选择就会受到很大的限制。是的。我的意思是，我认为对于初创公司来说，还有另一个挑战，那就是大多数风险投资家（VC）都在这里以及诸如此类的地方。所以让大家知道，VC就是风险投资家。所以这些人
the people who are going to take the risk, you know, and give your startup money before you've really built anything. But yeah, I mean, there's there's no reason why. Oh, well, there are reasons. But like Google could easily build a, you know, Google engineering office in Fargo. But then there's this question of like, what would happen if they did that? And that's the big unknown. But yeah, the that being low income is interesting because of what it really means but also why and your question of is it sustainable is is unknown right everybody tends to say this time is different and the fact that this isn't the first this time leads me to sort of bet against it being different this time yeah just as Just as a general rule, it seems like there's no obvious
就是那些愿意承担风险、并在你真正建立任何东西之前给你的初创公司投资钱的人。但是，是的，我的意思是，没有理由……哦，好吧，是有原因的。但就像谷歌完全可以在法戈建立一个谷歌工程办公室一样。然而这里就有一个问题：如果他们真的这么做了会发生什么？这是一个巨大的未知数。但是，是的，低收入（状况）之所以有趣，是因为它的真正含义，以及背后的原因。至于你问它是否可持续，这也是一个未知数，对吧？每个人都倾向于说“这次不一样”，而事实上这已经不是第一次了，这让我倾向于押注“这次其实并没有什么不同”。是的，就像
reason why it won't continue to be slightly worse and slightly worse. Yeah. I mean, I think, uh, I do think it will sort of plateau. Like there's been crazy growth recently. Um, I think, you know, at some point it will plateau, but I mean, I don't really see like a big crash. I mean, in general, I mean, I don't know if this, maybe this is just crazy talk, but, but I don't really see like a big crash. I mean, in general, I mean, I don't know if this maybe this is just crazy talk, but but I don't really think there's going to be these big crashes anymore. I mean, like in the market in general, in tech and real estate and just period, you know, like like the futures market is just so algorithmically dominated. And I feel like that gives it just a level of resilience that it just never really had before. And so even like if you look at the 2008 crash, it still took years or maybe at least 18 months for the crash. It wasn't like the 1930s or even 1998 where companies lost
作为一个一般规律，似乎没有什么明显的理由说明它不会继续变得稍微糟糕一点、再稍微糟糕一点。是的。我的意思是，我确实认为它会进入某种平台期。就像最近有疯狂的增长一样，我想，在某个时候它会进入平台期，但我真的不认为会出现一次大崩盘。总的来说，我是说，我不知道这——也许这只是疯话，但我真的不认为会有什么大崩盘。总的来说，我是说，我不知道这，也许这只是疯话，但我真的不认为以后还会有这种大崩盘。我是说，就像整个市场、科技领域、房地产领域以及整个宏观层面，你知道，就像期货市场现在被算法主导得太厉害了。我觉得这赋予了它一种前所未有过的韧性。所以即使你看2008年的崩盘，它仍然花了好几年、或者至少18个月的时间来崩盘。它不像20世纪30年代，甚至不像1998年那样，公司在两周内失去了
70% of their value in two weeks you know so yeah so you're claiming is this time is different i just think that there will be if there is going to be a decline it will be a slow decline i don't think that we will wake up there's people who say that yeah that we're less prone to bubbles than we used to be we're getting better at managing our bubbles exactly like it'll just be like it is a hypothesis the median house price will go from 900k to 800k over the next 30 years or something sure anyways that's my two cents uh don't don't don't buy uh don't bet on that yeah this is not financial advice don't worry it didn't sound very good advice anyways sorry i'm just teasing hey god i have to pull this dagger out of my heart
70%的价值，你知道的。所以，是的，你的主张是“这次不一样”，而我只是认为，如果有衰退的话，那将会是一次缓慢的衰退，我不认为我们会一觉醒来——有些人确实这么说，说我们比过去更不容易产生泡沫了，我们越来越擅长管理我们的泡沫了。完全如此，它只会像是一个假设，未来30年房价中位数将从90万降到80万左右，诸如此类。当然，不管怎样，这就是我的两点看法，呃，别买，呃，别押注那个。是的，这不是财务建议，别担心，听起来也不太像什么好建议。抱歉，我只是开个玩笑。天哪，我得把这把匕首从我心里拔出来。
well on something completely different it's not like uh it's not like i'm not reading economist books all the time right i mean you do so yeah i mean oh man that's your opinion man um that's true five react practice projects uh you can search that it'll be in the show notes um this was a page i found and in fact it's actually kind of bad i feel sad for recommending this because some of the links in here don't work anymore i guess they were referred to like a service that had some like kind of useful apis that is now down but this is really good collection i struggle with this a lot and you know a lot of people who are learning programming struggle with this which which is, okay, I learned like how to write a for loop. I learned how to make a web form. What next? Um, and actually coming up with well-defined beginner projects is really hard. Um, and so for me, this has always
好吧，说点完全不同的事。这并不是说——这并不是说我没有一直在读经济学书籍，对吧？我的意思是，你的确读了。所以，是的，噢天哪，那是你的看法，老兄。嗯，真的，“五个React实战项目”，你可以搜索一下，它会放在本期节目的shownotes（节目笔记）里。这是一个我找到的网页，事实上，它其实有点糟。为推荐这个我感到有点难过，因为这里面的某些链接已经失效了。我猜它们之前指向的是某个提供某种有用API的服务，现在已经关停了。但这是一个非常棒的合集。我在这方面挣扎了很久，而且你知道，很多正在学习编程的人也都在这方面挣扎，也就是：好吧，我学会了如何编写一个for循环，我学会了如何制作一个网页表单，接下来呢？嗯，实际上，想出定义明确的初创（新手）项目真的很难。嗯，所以对我和
been the case. Like I've always wanted to get into web development, get into, I mean, learn more about it. And one of the things I've struggled with is, oh, I know how to make a web page, like put HTML on a page. That's cool. I can, from JavaScript, from like a coding standpoint, I get, but there's a big gap in between that and making a full email client as a single page app
一直以来都是这样。就像我一直想进入Web开发领域，进入，我是说，了解更多这方面的知识。我挣扎的事情之一就是，哦，我知道怎么制作一个网页，比如在页面上放一段HTML。这很酷。从JavaScript的角度、从编写代码的角度来看，我懂了。但在这之间、以及制作一个作为单页应用运行在多台设备上的完整电子邮件客户端之间，存在着巨大的鸿沟
that runs on multiple devices or whatever, right? You know, like going from A to B, it's that, how do you draw an owl meme that's on reddit like first you draw like a circle and then you finish it and it's like yeah okay exactly anyways uh so this site i thought had some really reasonable or at least you know i'm not done web but they seem reasonable to me like a step of you know first try doing this then you can use it in the same way to do this other thing so the first one is like build uh what is it like a card like a social card like you would see someone who embedded a twitter message on their website and then build a weather app and how if
无论如何，从A点到B点，就像Reddit上那个“如何画猫头鹰”的梗一样：首先画一个圆，然后把它画完，然后就——是的，完全正确。不管怎样，呃，所以我认为这个网站有一些非常合理的——或者至少，呃，我虽然不做Web，但它们对我来说显得很合理——一个步骤，比如“首先尝试做这个”，然后你就可以用同样的方法去做另一件事。所以第一个就像是构建一个——这是什么？就像是一张卡片，一个社交卡片，就像你在某人的网站上看到有人嵌入了一条Twitter消息那样；然后构建一个天气应用。如果你
you build a weather widget app that you have like days of the week with some icons and you can just sort of like fake the data or or you know they recommend like oh maybe you could get this api um but those are like a series of those cards so it's sort of like building upon itself and i mean i don't know that these particular ones are the most amazing examples but i thought this is a good resource because i know for me it's really useful to have someone else who's already been down the path give a judgment on whether something contains an unforeseen difficulty that you won't be able to surmount yeah very cool yeah i've done some is this react native or react well i mean so i don't think i guess it kind of doesn't matter i guess it would be react web because most of this is talking about like a
构建了一个天气小部件应用，里面有一周中每天的天气和一些图标，你可以伪造一些数据，或者（你知道的）他们推荐说“哦，也许你可以获取这个API”。但这些都是一系列这样的卡片，所以它有点像是在此基础上不断叠加。我的意思是，我不知道这些特定的例子是不是最棒的，但我认为这是一个很好的资源，因为我知道对我来说，有一个已经走过这条路的人来判断某个东西是否包含你无法克服的未知困难，这是非常有用的一件事。是的，非常酷。是的，我做过一些，这是React Native还是React？好吧，我的意思是，所以我认为，我猜这其实没关系，我猜这应该是React Web，因为这其中的大部分都在讨论像
card you would embed in a website but it might be applicable to both it's not uh here's a bunch of code on exactly how to do it it's more like here's something you could go off and try to do okay go off and have this so the classic one for me is always oh i learned c like i want to write a video game how do i write a how do i draw a pixel on the screen and it's like oh well you could learn that it's not going to be easy or hard but at the same time recommending you to go work with a you know c++ game engine isn't also a great first step. Like it's an awkward thing, you know, which we've talked about before, like making a text-based game is much more approachable
你可以嵌入到网站中的卡片，但它可能两者都适用。它不是那种“这里有一堆关于具体怎么做的代码”的东西，它更像是“这里有一些你可以去尝试做的事情，去吧”。好吧，去试试吧。对我和我来说，经典的例子总是：哦，我学会了C语言，我想写一个电子游戏，我该怎么写？我怎么在屏幕上画一个像素？然后就变成：哦，好吧，你可以去学那个，这说不上容易还是难，但与此同时，推荐你去使用一个C++游戏引擎也不是一个很好的第一步。这真是一件很尴尬的事情，你知道的，正如我们之前讨论过的，做一个基于文本的游戏要比
than making a full-blown graphics game. Yep, exactly. So something similar for the web. Anyways, if it sounds useful, check out the show notes or just search five React practice projects. Cool. Yeah, very cool. Yeah, I think React Native and React.js, they're both great. I use them both uh
做一个成熟的图形游戏要平易近人得多。是的，完全正确。所以Web开发也有类似的东西。不管怎样，如果这听起来对你有用，去看看shownotes，或者直接搜索“五个React实战项目”。酷。是的，非常酷。是的，我认为React Native和React.js都很棒，我把它们都用在
in some some side projects and they worked out really well it's on my perpetual list of things to do one day nice nice um book of the show show my book of the show really quick is a critical play radical game design um yeah so i read this book uh i read this book last month and uh it was the only book i read last month last month was an extremely busy month for me and so i'll admit it wasn't that great i probably wouldn't buy it but you know sometimes we read books that that uh that aren't you know the best and you know we're totally honest i'll put the link up if you buy it we'll get some amazon money um but i but i wouldn't i mean i guess part of it was i was five stars would read again yeah this proves we're not shills right i was i was expecting um i guess i was expecting radical
我的一些副业项目里了，效果非常好。它在我的“有朝一日要做的事情”无限清单上。太棒了，太棒了。嗯，本期秀的书——非常快地讲一下我的本期推荐书籍，是一本叫《批判性游玩：激进游戏设计》（Critical Play: Radical Game Design）。嗯，所以这本书我读了——我上个月读了这本书，而且这是我上个月读的唯一一本书。上个月对我来说极其忙碌，所以我承认这本书其实没那么好，我可能不会买它。但你知道，有时我们读的书，呃，并不是（你知道的）最好的，我们要完全诚实。我会把链接放上去，如果你买的话，我们会得到一些亚马逊的分成。但我不——我的意思是，我猜其中一部分原因是，五星推荐，还会再读。是的，这证明了我们不是托儿，对吧？我当时——我当时在期待，
game design to mean um uh like really um like a chronology of really innovative things like for example uh so one thing that comes to my mind is is tower defense so uh have you played these tower defense games yeah i think i've played a few okay like defense grid kingdom rush there's a gazillion of them now but the idea with tower defense games is um there's there's some enemies and they're just walking across the and they're just walking across the screen they're they have nothing to do with you they just want to get from left side screen the right side screen and what you could do is build these little towers the towers don't move but they have a little circular radius and anything in that radius is
我猜我是期待“激进游戏设计”意味着，呃，真正像是一部极具创新性的东西的编年史。例如，呃，有一个在我脑海中浮现的东西就是“塔防（Tower Defense）”。所以，呃，你玩过这些塔防游戏吗？是的，我想我玩过几个。好吧，就像《防御阵型》（Defense Grid）、《王国保卫战》（Kingdom Rush）一样，现在有无数个这样的游戏。但塔防游戏的概念是，呃，有一些敌人，它们正穿过——它们正穿过屏幕，它们和你没有任何关系，它们只想从屏幕左侧走到屏幕右侧。而你能做的是建造这些小塔，这些塔不会移动，但它们有一个小的圆形半径，在该半径内的任何东西都会
going to take some damage over time um and the name of the game is you have to strategize and build and upgrade the towers so that the people can't get from the left to the the name of the game is you have to strategize and build and upgrade the towers so that the people can't get from the left to the right side of the screen. So if you build, you know, and you have to trade off, like, I could build three towers, or I could build one tower and upgrade it a bunch. And so you have to like really look at the, you know, the spec sheet to figure out like what is optimal and all of that um and space is a constraint anyways so so that to me was like a radical game design and someone actually made that as a mod to starcraft one at least that's the first time i saw it um and and the reason is is
随着时间的推移受到一些伤害。游戏的秘诀在于，你必须制定策略，建造和升级防御塔，以便人们无法从左侧走到——游戏的秘诀在于，你必须制定策略，建造和升级防御塔，以便人们无法从左侧走到屏幕右侧。所以如果你建造，（你知道的）你必须进行权衡，比如我可以建造三座塔，或者我可以建造一座塔并把它升级很多次。所以你必须真正查看规格表，以弄清楚什么是最佳方案以及所有这些。而且空间是一个限制因素。不管怎样，所以对我来说，这就像是激进的游戏设计，而且有人实际上把这作为《星际争霸1》的一个模组（Mod）制作了出来，至少这是我第一次见到它。而且原因在于，
starcraft the the editor you know it was pretty limited but this was one of the games that you could build in it and so it was sort of just emergent based on you know the the limitations of that of that editor and the fact that it was so easy to make a game inside of starcraft and deploy it to millions of people um so that that in my opinion like that was something i wanted to see but instead the whole book was all about basically games as art. And so it talked about like really things that were kind of out there. Like there was a museum that had a game where, you know, you like walked through the museum as part of the game. I guess it was just more about it was just much more connected to art.
《星际争霸》的编辑器，你知道的，相当受限。但这是你可以在其中构建的游戏之一，所以它某种程度上只是根据那个编辑器的局限性以及在《星际争霸》内部制作游戏并将其部署给数百万玩家是多么容易而自然涌现出来的。所以依我之见，那是我想要看到的东西。但相反，整本书基本上都在讲“游戏作为艺术”。所以它谈论了很多那种比较奇特的、边缘的东西。比如有一个博物馆里有一个游戏，你知道的，你作为游戏的一部分走过博物馆。我猜它只是更多地关乎——它与艺术的联系要紧密得多。
It talked a lot about museums, talked a lot about museums talk a lot about different art styles um there were it was a lot of talking about like games that there's this game i guess that talked about kind of getting cancer and they spent a lot of time talking about that and so you know i think i guess what when they thought of game design they were really thinking about you know designing games to to affect a certain emotion. And they were really taking sort of that approach. And so in that sense, the book is pretty myopic. If you go on, let's say, Wikipedia and you look at different game genres and you take that approach to game design, this book's going of let you down which is what it did to me so if you're interested in seeing like really crazy games uh like there's
它谈论了很多关于博物馆的内容，谈论了很多关于博物馆谈论不同艺术风格的内容。有很多关于——谈论一些关于游戏的讨论，有一个游戏我猜是关于患癌症的，他们花了很多时间讨论这个。所以，你知道，我想当他们想到游戏设计时，他们真正想到的是，你知道的，设计游戏来引发某种特定的情感。他们真正采用的是那种方法。所以从这个意义上说，这本书是相当目光短浅的。如果你去——比方说——维基百科，看看不同的游戏类型，然后用那种方法来看游戏设计，这本书会让你失望的，这也是它对我的影响。所以如果你有兴趣看看真正疯狂的游戏，呃，就像
one game you might have heard this game patrick america's army have you heard of this the one that was paid for by the actual u.s army yes so so yeah there was a game that was literally made by the army and uh it was it was it was basically meant to to get people excited about the army. Or at least I was like, you know, I guess one of the goals. And so this book talks a lot about that and social implications of that and things like that. So I have to admit, like, I found the book interesting, but it just I felt like the title is misleading. And so it's kind of like, uh, um, you know, if someone hands you like a grapefruit and you bite it and it's actually like an orange, like a blood orange or something, you know, that's not going to taste good because you're
有一个游戏你可能听说过这个游戏，帕特里克，“美国陆军”（America's Army），你听说过这个吗？那个由真正的美国陆军出资赞助的游戏？是的，所以，是的，有一个游戏真的是由军队制作的，呃，它基本上是为了让人们对军队感到兴奋，或者至少我当时想，你知道，我猜这是目标之一。所以这本书谈了很多关于这方面的内容以及它的社会含义等等。所以我必须承认，我发现这本书很有趣，但它只是——我觉得书名具有误导性。所以这有点像，呃，你知道的，如果有人递给你一个西红柿（编者注：原文为grapefruit西柚），你咬了一口，发现它其实是个橙子，比如血橙什么的，你知道的，那尝起来不会好喝，因为你
expecting one thing and you got something else. And that's kind of how, kind of how I felt with this book. Like, you know, it looked like, looked like one thing, but then when I read it, it was something totally different. It kind of let me down. My book of the show gets five stars. Oh, wow. I'm not going to tell you what it is. No, I'm just kidding. Unless you read the bad book first. After someone emails us a receipt of having read Jason's book.
期待的是一样东西，结果却得到了另一些东西。这就是我读这本书时的感觉。就像，你知道的，它看起来像是一回事，但当我读完后，它完全是另一回事。它有点让我失望。我本期推荐的书得到五星好评。哦，哇。我不会告诉你那是什么。不，我开玩笑的。除非有人给我们发来购买了杰森推荐的那本烂书的收据。
So I actually had a different book, which I also would have probably given five stars. But I had a different book. And then somebody had contacted Jason because i'm a social media hermit um and this is true i have to relay yeah he sends me screenshots of people who uh who message him so thank you all jason will continue to serve as my secretary so if you have anything you would like to tell me just let him know hey carrier pigeon oh okay give credit words okay uh and he this was christian uh and he messaged jason was like oh hey patrick and i have a lot of the same taste you should recommend this book to him and turned out i was like uh of course i've already had that as my book of the show like
所以我其实有另一本书，我可能也会给它五星好评。但我有另一本书。然后有人联系了杰森，因为我是社交媒体隐士，这是真的，我得转达一下。是的，他发给我一些给他发消息的人的截屏。所以谢谢大家，杰森将继续担任我的秘书，所以如果你有什么想对我说的话，直接告诉他就行了。嘿，信鸽！哦，好吧，给点功劳，好吧，嗯。他——这是克里斯蒂安（Christian）——他给杰森发消息说：“哦，嘿，帕特里克和我有很多相同的品味，你应该把这本书推荐给他。”结果我说：“呃，当然，我已经把这本作为我本期的推荐书了。”为什么这家伙会——你知道的——给杰森发这个消息？这太奇怪了。
why did this guy like you know message jason about this is weird uh and then i said wait i've never had this as book of the show and then i was when we were getting the show notes together, I was, you know, looking through and it's, oh, the reason why is that there's two books in this series so far. And the first book came out before we started recording Programming Throwdown. And the second book came out before we started book of the show on programming throwdown uh and so i've never featured either the first or second book from the series and so i'll start off by recommending the first book but i have actually read them read them uh many moons ago and uh they are really good books but i will warn you the series is not complete uh and as you've i've already spoiled
然后我说：“等等，我从来没把这个作为过本期推荐书啊。”然后当我们在整理shownotes的时候，我——你知道的——翻看了一下，哦，原因在于这个系列目前有两本书。第一本书出版于我们开始录制《编程爆料》（Programming Throwdown）之前。第二本书出版于我们开始在《编程爆料》中设立“本期推荐书”环节之前。所以这两本书我从来没有在节目里推荐过第一本或第二本。所以我将从推荐第一本开始，但我其实已经读过它们了——很久很久以前读过——它们真的是很好的书。但我得警告你，这个系列还没有完结。正如我刚才已经剧透的，
die only two of the three books are out and the second book came out before we started having Book of the Show, and this podcast is going on many number of years now. The author is unknown as to when the third book will be releasing. So if you don't like reading unfinished series, which is now a thing, you have to be careful, then I would recommend waiting until the third book comes out. And that is The Name of the Wind by Patrick Rothfuss. So very, very, very, very good book.
三本书中只有两本出版了，而且第二本是在我们开始有“本期推荐书”环节之前出版的，这个播客已经运营了很多年了。至于第三本书什么时候出版，作者并没有公布。所以如果你不喜欢阅读未完结的系列——这现在也算是一种情况了，你得小心——那么我建议等到第三本书出版了再看。那本书就是帕特里克·罗福斯（Patrick Rothfuss）的《风之名》（The Name of the Wind）。所以这是一本非常、非常、非常、非常好的书。
Highly recommend it. But also very frustrating that the first two books and we're still waiting on a third book for going on 10 years now. No, the first book came out more than 10 years ago. The second book came out and it is not quite been that long, but it's been a long time. I'll have to look it up here. And anyway, so it's a book about a fantasy book.
强烈推荐。但也非常令人沮丧，因为前两本出了之后，我们还在等第三本，已经等了快10年了。不，第一本是10多年前出的。第二本也出了，虽然还没那么久，但也已经很久了。我得在这里查一下。不管怎样，所以这是一本关于——一本奇幻书。
And it was March 1st, 2011. So we're at seven years since the last book came. And so Name of the Wind is a book, a fantasy book about a man named kvothe and his uh experiences that i can't i never know what to say i don't want to spoil things uh but there's some magic in the book the way the magic works is is really good and interesting and i like it uh that's a very sort of um it sounds bad like a realistic approach to magic like is that i think i've said that about other books surely it's kind of based in some kind of alchemy or something yeah like they try
它出版于2011年3月1日。所以距离上一本书出版已经过去七年了。所以《风之名》是一本关于一个名叫库夫（Kvothe）的男人的奇幻书，以及他的——呃——经历。我总是不知道该说些什么，我不想剧透。但书里有一些魔法，魔法运作的方式真的很好、很有趣，我很喜欢。这是一种非常——呃——听起来可能不太好，就像是对魔法的一种现实主义的处理方法。我想我以前对别的书也这么说过，它确实有点某种炼金术之类的基础。是的，就像他们试图
to come up with some consistent rules and how it would work and like trying to abide by those rules um which i guess is an art it's a game we all agree to play in our heads let's say that way but yeah this game has interesting rules um and they're well thought through and the world building is good um and i i definitely really really really enjoyed this book i think i picked it up a couple times and didn't really and then you know sort of had a little bit of a rough start was busy and then but when i once i finally got in like i'm gonna read this uh it was really good uh and then the second book um not quite as good as the first book but second books are always kind of hard to write i guess um and i'm not an author but authors say that the second
想出一些一致的规则以及它是如何运作的，并试图遵守这些规则。我想这也是一门艺术，这是我们大家同意在脑海中玩的一个游戏，不妨这么说。但是，是的，这个游戏有有趣的规则，它们经过深思熟虑，世界观构建得很好，我绝对、绝对、绝对非常喜欢这本书。我想我拿起来过好几次，一开始没有真正读进去，然后（你知道的）有点开局不顺，很忙，但是一旦我真正沉下心来告诉自己“我要读完它”，它就真的非常棒。然后第二本书，虽然没有第一本那么好，但第二本书总是有点难写，我想。我虽然不是作家，但作家们都说第二本书更难写。这说得很通，我的意思是，你真的被第一本书给定型（calcified）了，你不能回去改变历史。然后，你在试图设定、试图收尾一些情节、建立你自己的故事线的同时，还要为下一本做铺垫——
books are harder to write it makes sense i mean you're you're you're uh you're really like uh calcified by the first book like you can't go back and change history right and then and then the third and you're trying to set up like you're trying to wrap up some stuff have your own story arc but set up some stuff for the next book um unless you're just having a two book series in which case i don't know but if you're having a three or four or five book series um yeah that second one i think is a little tough sometimes um but i still enjoyed the second book so the one thing i will say that is sort of a funny uh instance if you do read this book in the second book so it's a book and in the book someone's telling a story and in the story they're telling there's people like writing books and telling stories and at some point you realize you're like four or five stories deep in this book
除非你只是写一个两本完结的系列，这种情况下我不知道；但如果你写的是一个三部曲、四部曲或五部曲，呃，第二本有时候确实有点难。但我还是很喜欢第二本。所以我要说的一个有趣的例子是，如果你读这本书，在第二本书里——这是一本书，在书里有人在讲故事，而在他们讲述的故事里，有人在写书、在讲故事。在某个时刻你会意识到，你在这本书里已经深入了四到五层故事！
nice and so uh it's like one of the i don't know i almost feel like i when i realized this i sort of chuckled and felt like somebody was like challenging themselves like how it's the inception thing like how many recursive stories can i have going on at one time so like i'm telling a story to jason about a dream i had and in that dream i was reading a book and in that book there was a storyteller and the storyteller was telling a story about a man who wrote a book and you're just like oh what okay anyways that's got to be really hard if you put that book down which one to pick it back which where along the stack yeah you definitely will have a stack fault if you have to go back six months later and try to
太妙了。所以，呃，这就像其中一个——我不知道，我甚至觉得当我意识到这一点时，我轻笑了一声，感觉就像有人在挑战自己——这就是《盗梦空间》的桥段，我能同时进行多少个递归故事？所以就像我在给杰森讲一个关于我做过的梦的故事，而在那个梦里我在读一本书，在那本书里有一个讲故事的人，而那个讲故事的人正在讲一个关于一个写书的男人的故事……你会觉得：哦，什么？好吧。不管怎样，如果你把那本书放下，这一定很难重新捡起来——你该从堆栈的哪一个位置继续？是的，如果你在六个月后不得不回去试图记住发生了什么，你肯定会遇到“堆栈溢出”（stack fault）。
remember what happened so and it's but uh yeah definitely so i'm not saying very much because i never do but name of the wind fantasy magic uh world building uh definitely not short book uh so if that if that seems to strike your fancy then you've probably already heard about it and you've probably already read it but if you haven't then do five stars don't read jason's book my book's better all right sounds good you can also get patrick's book on amazon using our link and uh that helps us helps out the show cool um we also if you don't want to buy his book uh on amazon the the the uh i guess the the written version the scripted version i don't know what the word is you can buy the written version, the scripted version. I don't know what the word is. You can buy the audio version from Audible. And you can go to audibletrial.com slash programmingthrowdown.
所以，呃——是的，我没说太多，因为我从来都不多说。但《风之名》、奇幻、魔法、世界观构建，绝对不是一本短书。所以如果这听起来很合你的心意，你可能已经听说过它，也可能已经读过了；但如果你还没读过，给它五星好评！别读杰森的书，我的书更好。好的，听起来不错。你也可以通过我们的链接在亚马逊上买到帕特里克的书，呃，那会对我们有帮助，对节目也有帮助。酷。嗯，我们还——如果你不想在亚马逊上买他的书——呃——纸质版、剧本版，我不知道那个词是什么——你可以买有声书版本，在Audible上。你可以访问 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown。
We have a link in the show notes. And you get a free book. And you start your trial. And that also helps us out. You can also donate to our Patreon, patreon.com slash programmingthrowdown. And I actually got all the thank you letters printed out and uh i'm waiting patrick and i have to meet up so that he can sign them oh i know this is this is the longest christmas present wait what i didn't really oh no well yeah we you have some
我们在shownotes里有一个链接。你可以得到一本免费的书，并开始你的试用。那也会对我们有帮助。你也可以捐助我们的Patreon，patreon.com/programmingthrowdown。我其实已经把所有的感谢信都打印出来了，呃，我正等着——我和帕特里克得碰个面，好让他把它们签了。哦，我知道，这是史上最漫长的圣诞礼物等待。什么？我没有真的——哦，不，好吧，是的，你有很多
signing to do buddy oh oh boy so we'll meet up we'll uh We'll sign them all. And then we will send them off to you folks. And we have everyone's address. A couple of people emailed me, by the way, saying, hey, this is my address. You know, last minute. It's totally fine. Not a problem. We should probably recheck if anyone's moved. Yeah, if you've moved, tell us.
要签名的地方呢，老兄！哦，哦，天哪。所以我们会碰面，呃，我们会把它们全签了。然后我们会把它们寄给各位。我们有每个人的地址。顺便说一句，有几个人给我发邮件说：“嘿，这是我的地址。”你知道的，在最后一分钟。这完全没问题，没问题。我们可能应该重新核实一下是否有人搬过家。是的，如果你搬家了，告诉我们。
Yeah. Yeah, that's true. Well, yeah, I'll send them out ASAP. And if you moved, we'll send another one. Tool of the show. Wow, that was awesome. My tool of the show is Visual Studio Code. I actually made this tool before we decided to talk about GitHub.
是的，是的，那倒是。好吧，我会尽快把它们寄出去。如果你搬家了，我们会再寄一份。本期工具。哇，太棒了。我本期推荐的工具是Visual Studio Code。我其实在这个工具之前就决定聊GitHub了。
But it's amazing. I actually, this is going to surprise people. I stopped using Emacs. I just switched to this. I take it back i still use emacs so this is like most of the graphical ids it's project based so um you know if you're editing like a random file in your home directory um it doesn't make sense like start a visual studio code um but uh for for all of my like projects i'm using visual studio code i love it um it's really really nice
但它太棒了。实际上，这会让人感到惊讶，我不再使用Emacs了，我刚刚转到了这个。我收回前话，我还在用Emacs。所以，就像大多数图形化IDE一样，它是基于项目的。所以，呃，你知道的，如果你在编辑你主目录下的一个随机文件，启动Visual Studio Code是没有意义的。但是，呃，对于我所有的项目，我都在使用Visual Studio Code，我爱死它了。它真的、真的很好。
um it uh it's extremely fast which is really surprising because it's it's much faster actually than atom and atom itself is is is so fast it almost doesn't matter um but this thing like doesn't you know burn up your battery um it's extremely slick now Now people might say, oh, Visual Studio, that's been around since the 90s. Visual Studio Code is totally different. So Visual Studio Code is an IDE written, it's a fork of Atom, and it has no relation to Visual Studio, I guess proper, or what have you.
嗯，它——极其快，这真的很令人惊讶，因为它实际上比Atom快得多，而Atom本身就已经快到几乎可以忽略不计了。但这个东西——不会（你知道的）耗尽你的电池。它现在极其流畅。
It has an amazing sort of plugin ecosystem. So I was immediately able to get like a CMake plugin, a C++ plugin, a Python plugin. I installed, there's a, actually it was a tool of the show a while back, Editor Config, which is a style guide plugin. It has support for almost anything, even like Thrift and protocol buffer, syntax highlighting. It has all that stuff. The plugin system is great. Editor is great.
人们可能会说：“哦，Visual Studio，那不是从90年代就有了吗？”Visual Studio Code完全不同。所以Visual Studio Code是一个编写好的IDE，它是Atom的一个分支（fork），我猜它和Visual Studio本身或诸如此类没有关系。它拥有一个令人惊叹的插件生态系统。所以我立刻就能装上CMake插件、C++插件、Python插件。我还安装了——其实它也是不久前本期推荐的工具——Editor Config，这是一个代码风格指南插件。它支持几乎所有东西，甚至是Thrift和Protocol Buffer的语法高亮。它拥有所有这些东西。插件系统很棒，编辑器很棒。
I actually know a buddy who switched to it too, and he loves it. And yeah, check it out. I mean, I am really, really surprised. If you use like Sublime or Atom or, you know, one of these editors that's kind of in the ballpark of Visual Studio Code, definitely check out Visual Studio Code. It might be worth the switch. I used to do a lot of stuff in just Emacs. And like I said, I pretty much switched. I spend 90% of time in this now.
我其实认识一个朋友也转到了这个，他非常喜欢它。是的，去看看吧。我是说，我真的、真的感到很惊讶。如果你使用的是Sublime、Atom，或者（你知道的）任何这类处于Visual Studio Code周边的编辑器，一定要去看看Visual Studio Code。它可能非常值得你切换过去。我以前在纯Emacs里做很多事情。就像我说的，我已经基本转过去了。我现在90%的时间都在用这个。
So check it out. So one caveat is it's not a fork of Atom. They use the same framework, Electron, that GitHub built for Atom. Oh, I see. But it's not actually a fork, or at least so the internets tell me. Okay, yeah, I'm glad you mentioned that. I don't know how I knew that. I feel like somebody at work, I think, told me that, but I never really thought.
所以去看看吧。不过需要注意的一点是，它不是Atom的分支。它们使用了相同的框架——Electron，那是GitHub为Atom构建的。哦，我明白了。但它实际上不是一个分支，或者至少互联网是这么告诉我的。好吧，是的，我很高兴你提到这一点。我不知道我是怎么知道的。我觉得好像是公司的某个人告诉过我的，但我从来没真正去想过。
You probably read it on the internet. Just like I read my thing on the internet, and i don't know who we can trust either way it's uh it's it's it's really really well done um definitely recommend using it so the people who who built that again jason the adam engine electron oh yeah github my tool of the show is github your tool of the show is worth 7.5 billion dollars boom fortunately it doesn't cost that much to use yeah totally free no so jason and i were talking about this before but i mean github if you you know want to and maybe there's even been a tool to show before we try to check and we don't think it was but if you're you know trying to share your code with people um rather than emailing around in a file like we used to, I mean, you should be posting it on GitHub. You should be if you're not currently working and you're in school and you want to get used to sort of how teams do stuff, you know, and how source control works, which we've talked about before.
你可能是从互联网上读到的。就像我从互联网上读到我的东西一样，我也不知道我们该相信谁。不管怎样，它——它——它真的、真的做得很好，绝对推荐使用。所以，再次构建那个的人，杰森，Atom引擎，Electron……哦，对了，GitHub。我本期推荐的工具是GitHub。你本期推荐的工具价值75亿美元！轰！幸运的是，使用它的成本没那么高。完全免费，没有。所以杰森和我之前讨论过这个，但我的意思是，如果你——你知道的——想要分享你的代码，也许以前的节目也推荐过某个工具，我们试着查了一下，觉得好像没有。但如果你（你知道的）正试图和别人分享你的代码，而不是像我们以前那样用电子邮件传来传去一个文件，我是说，你应该把它发布到GitHub上。如果你目前没有工作、还在上学，并且想习惯团队是如何协作的、版本控制是如何运作的（我们之前讨论过），
You know, you can get on GitHub, make a public repository and then you can put it on your resume, you know, fork people on GitHub, all that good stuff. We really take GitHub for granted. But I want to talk about it as a tool to show for sort of one specific use, which is going in and trying to find for, you know, projects that you know are in the language you're using or big and looking as examples on how to do stuff. So I found a lot of use of going in on big projects and searching for functions or things and just getting a feel for how they've decided to use something. So I'll try to find out if a project like, you know, an example, I don't, this isn't true, but like, oh, I'm using some boost library. And I'm really struggling with like, hey, how should I really use this? Or what's a good invocation pattern for doing this?
你知道的，你可以上GitHub，做一个公开的仓库（repository），然后你可以把它写进简历里，在GitHub上fork别人的项目，所有这些好东西。我们真的把GitHub视为理所当然。但我想把它作为本期推荐的工具来谈谈它的一个特定用途，那就是进入并试图寻找——你知道的——你正在使用的语言的大型项目，以此作为如何做事的范例。所以我发现进入大型项目并搜索函数或事物，从而对他们如何决定使用某种东西有一种直观感受，是非常有用的。所以我会试着找出某个项目是否——打个比方，这不是真的，但就像“哦，我正在使用某个Boost库。我真的很纠结：嘿，我到底该怎么用它？或者这样做有什么好的调用模式吗？”
And I'll go on to GitHub and try to find a project that uses that Boost library and look at how they're doing it. So this sort of code searching ability. The one thing is that I wish they would do, which they don't, you have to already be in a repository in order to be able to search. And I wish they would let you sort of search across. Oh, I can give you a power tip. Oh, is it?
然后我会去GitHub上找一个使用那个Boost库的项目，看看他们是怎么做的。所以这种代码搜索能力。我唯一希望他们能做到但他们却没有做到的是，你必须已经身处一个仓库中才能进行搜索。我希望他们能让你跨仓库搜索。哦，我可以给你一个高级技巧。哦，是吗？
Basically, I have a shortcut which does a Google search, but it forces the site to be github.com. Oh, okay. There we go. All right. So there you go. GitHub's my tool of the show. Very nice.
基本上，我有一个快捷方式可以进行谷歌搜索，但它强制限定搜索网站是github.com。哦，好吧。原来如此。好吧，给你找到了。GitHub是我本期推荐的工具。非常棒。
Yeah, GitHub's amazing. You can actually see I'm in the middle of a technical argument on GitHub, actually, with the owners of HyperJS. Oh. You can see I'm trying to use all of these skills that we're going to talk about on the technical arguments show. And so we're going to talk all about uh you know we've been doing this for a long time and uh we've seen a whole bunch of different arguments um obviously any job has arguments we're going to try to we're not going to talk about like i don't know political arguments or argument over who has the best sports team or something like that i mean we're going to
是的，GitHub太棒了。实际上你可以看到我正处于GitHub上的一场技术争论中，对方是HyperJS的维护者。哦。你可以看到我正试图在技术争论节目中运用所有这些我们将要讨论的技巧。所以我们要讨论的全都是——你知道的——我们已经做这个很久了，我们见过各种各样不同的争论。显然任何工作都有争论，我们要讨论的不会是——我不知道，政治争论，或者关于谁拥有最好的运动队的争论之类的。我是说，我们会
try we're going to keep it very specific um but, you know, some of the things I'm sure we'll translate or we'll generalize. But, you know, we've seen a lot of, there's a lot of different arguments, a lot of contention, right? And as you can imagine, a lot of it centers around different sort of design decisions and things like that, but it can get all the way down to, you know, where you put the semicolons and all of that. So we're going to talk about all of that. So we try to break it down into a couple of sections and just sort of some themes. So we'll see how this goes.
尽量让它非常具体。但是，你知道，我相信其中一些内容会转化或泛化。不过，你知道，我们见过很多争论，有很多不同的对立观点，对吧？正如你所想象的，其中很多都围绕着不同的设计决策等等，但它甚至可以一直深入到——你知道的——你把分号放在哪里之类的小事。所以我们要讨论所有这些。我们试着把它分解成几个部分以及一些主题。我们拭目以待。
But the first one I have is this debate about trying to get things done versus doing the right thing. This one's really tough. I mean, I don't know that there's, there isn't, in fact, almost all of these, there isn't a right answer, which is why they're hot topics to debate. That's right. This one, I would say even more so than maybe almost, I'm trying to read this list really quick while I
不过我提出的第一个问题，是关于“力求完成任务”与“做正确的事”之间的辩论。这个真的很难。我是说，我不知道有没有——事实上，几乎所有这些问题都没有标准答案，这也是它们成为热门辩论话题的原因。没错。这个问题，我甚至可以说，比几乎所有其他问题都更……我得快点读完这份清单，免得
don't lose my talking pace. This one might be the hardest one. This one comes up all the time, just like on, and at every scale. So you could imagine like an entire company having the debate about, and that is like when to do the right thing versus when to just get it done. And this comes up at like, you know, should we ship this product? Should we, you know, ditch it and try another prototype? You know, all the way down to just things in your code like, you know, oh, I could just, you know, declare a global variable here and be done with this. Or I could sit here and try to think about what the right way to refactor it would be.
打乱了说话的节奏。这个问题可能最难。这个问题随时随地都在出现，而且在各个层面都是如此。你可以想象一下，整个公司都在争论这个问题，那就是：什么时候该做正确的事，什么时候该直接把活干完。这会在很多情况下出现，比如，你知道的：我们应该发布这个产品吗？我们应该放弃它并尝试另一个原型吗？甚至一直细化到代码中的具体事情，比如：哦，我可以在这里声明一个全局变量，然后就搞定了。或者我可以坐在这里，花时间思考重构它的正确方式是什么。
And, you know, it's from the start of your project when you're saying, like, let me just get something banged out and iterate it to like, let me sit down and come up with, you know, a full on UML diagram and architecture of everything I want to build. I'll write my test first and do test driven development. Like you're you might be doing it right, but your first bit of code, you know, might not come out for a long time. This is this is really tough. And a lot of this there's lots and lots of factors that come into here. But part of it is, if you ever have a deadline, and whether you were asked for input on when, what was a reasonable deadline or not, I mean, deadlines exist, they come up, and you always end up against the wall. And missing a deadline often has sort of bad consequences. And sometimes you need to sort of not do the right thing in order to hit the deadline. The problem is, if you don't strike the balance then you build up what we called sort of
你知道的，从项目一开始，当你在说“让我先随便敲点东西出来然后进行迭代”，到“让我坐下来，为我要构建的一切想出一个全面的UML图和架构。我要先写测试，搞测试驱动开发。”你会觉得，你的做法可能没错，但你的第一行代码可能要过很久才能出来。这真的非常难。这里面涉及非常非常多的因素。但部分原因在于，如果你面临截止日期——不管当初有没有人征求你对合理截止日期的意见——我是说，截止日期就是客观存在的，它们会出现，而你总是会被逼到墙角。错过截止日期通常会带来不好的后果。有时为了赶上截止日期，你不得不选择不做正确的事。问题是，如果你没有把握好平衡，就会积累起我们所说的
technical debt and technical debt just means exactly that like you were trying to get something done quick or you didn't know the right answer and so you just did whatever came to mind and now you have some bit of code which later will come to need to be refactored or will slow down programmer efficiency or increase i always use this term a lot the increase the cognitive burden of your code which is like how many things you need to hold in your head to to do this or is it completely obvious on reading it um and these things is a really difficult balance to strike. But I think this one is probably the one that comes up almost continually while you're working. Yeah, that makes sense.
技术债务。技术债务的意思恰恰就是字面那样：你当时为了快点完成任务，或者因为不知道正确的答案，于是就随便想了个办法应付过去，结果现在有了一段代码，以后将不得不对其进行重构，这会降低程序员的工作效率，或者增加——我经常用这个词——增加代码的认知负担。也就是你在做这件事时，脑子里需要同时记住多少事情，或者别人在阅读代码时它是不是完全显而易见的。嗯，要平衡好这些事情真的非常困难。但我认为，这个问题大概是你在工作时会不断遇到的一个。是的，这说得通。
I mean, one thing I would add to that is, you know, sometimes you have these external deadlines, right? Like, let's say you have a product manager or some program manager and they're setting the deadlines or something like that. But then, you know, there's many times where you are sort of in charge of that. And even then, it's not trivial. Basically, you like, you know, the product itself is sort of an unknown, right? Like you don't know exactly what you're building and what it's going to look like and how people are going to react to it and all of that. I mean, if you are, like, for example,
我是说，对此我要补充的一点是，你知道的，有时你会遇到这些外部的deadline（截止日期），对吧？比如，假设你有一个产品经理或某个项目经理，他们在设定截止日期之类的。但随后，你知道的，很多时候你是负责掌控这个进度的。即便如此，这也不是一件轻而易举的事。基本上，你会发现产品本身就像是个未知数，对吧？比如你并不知道自己具体在构建什么，它最终会变成什么样，人们会对此有什么反应，诸如此类。我是说，如果你在做的事情是，比如说
if you are building like a chip and you're implementing the floating point operator or something like that, that's a very different environment. Those environments are usually just extremely controlled and regimented and they can be, right? But if you're building, let's say an app, the first few months of the app, you might just be trying to find out what people want and how to sort of reconcile the things that you want to offer with the market
如果你正在制造一款芯片，并且在实现浮点运算器之类的东西，那完全是另一个环境。这些环境通常极其受控、井然有序，而且也必须如此，对吧？但如果你在构建的是，比如说一款应用（app），那么这款应用最初的几个月里，你可能只是在摸索人们到底想要什么，以及如何把你想要提供的东西与市场需求
and what they want to consume. And so your app, like on the surface, it might be changing massively from one day to the next. And you're incurring a lot of technical debt and the code is super ugly. And that is good, right? You don't want to take the approach of someone who's designing like, you know, the next Intel chip when you're making this app,
以及他们想要消费什么。因此，你的应用表面上可能每天都在发生巨大的变化。你承担了大量的技术债务，而且代码也非常丑陋。这其实是件好事，对吧？当你在制作这个应用时，你可不想采用那种像是在设计下一代英特尔芯片的人的方法，
because then you can't really navigate that space quickly, right? And so that's why it's difficult is you're sort of trading off, let's say, learning and exploring with, as Patrick said, like building something that, you know, can allow you to scale to the next level. So if you just focus on exploring, you end up with something that's too fragile for you to, you know, use it as a platform for the next thing. And so yeah, trading that off is extremely difficult. And I think here, the way to sort of resolve arguments like this is to just understand that dynamic right and so um um so so what that means is you know if the app if you're still trying to figure out what you're doing
因为那样的话，你就无法在那个领域中灵活穿梭了，对吧？这就是为什么它很难，因为正如帕特里克所说，你是在权衡学习与探索，以及构建能够让你扩展到下一阶段的东西。所以，如果你只专注于探索，你最终得到的成果会过于脆弱，以至于无法将其用作下一步发展的平台。所以，权衡这两者极其困难。我认为在这里，解决这类争论的方法就是理解这种动态，所以……所以这意味着，如果这款应用、如果你还在摸索自己在做什么，
then uh you need then you sort of relax right a lot of these like just you know like over engineering like you don't over design things but then on the flip side, you know that you're going to have to pay that price later. So, you know, when the app is done and they say, OK, the app does music. Now let's make it, you know, play videos, too. And let's do the next version of it. That's when you just say, whoa, wait a minute. You know, we need to sort of redo this because we didn't even know we thought that this was a dating app and now we're a music player and so so along the way we've made a lot of bad decisions we need to now go through and like redo everything so i feel like if you can kind of gauge that ebb and flow of your project that will sort of give you the the um insight that you need to like win that, that argument or make the most compelling argument, you know,
那么……你就可以放松要求，对吧？很多诸如此类的东西，比如过度工程化——你不会过度设计各种事情。但另一方面，你知道你以后必须为之付出代价。所以，当应用做好了，他们说：“好了，这个应用现在能播放音乐了。现在让我们也让它支持播放视频吧，并做下一个版本。”这时候你就要说：“等等，等等。我们需要重新做一遍，因为我们甚至不知道……我们原以为这是一款约会应用，而现在我们成了一个音乐播放器。所以在这一过程中，我们做出了很多糟糕的决定，我们现在必须回过头来把一切推倒重来。”所以我觉得，如果你能把握好项目这种起伏的节奏，就能获得所需的洞察力，从而在面对这种争论时赢得辩论，或者提出最有说服力的论点。
when it comes to that. Yeah. I guess this one also is, is difficult because it comes down to the like true cost of things, which is if you take a long time to build the most amazing platform ever, and you never ship your product, you're going to go bankrupt. Right. Yeah. So like, what is the first, like in different industries
以及他们的消费需求协调起来。所以你的应用表面上可能从一天到下一天发生巨大的改变。你会背负大量的技术债务，代码也超级丑。而这其实是件好事，对吧？在做这款应用时，你可不想采用那种设计下一代英特尔芯片的人所使用的方法，
and in different applications, like first mover advantage is different. So if you're building an airplane, it needs to be safe. It needs to be a lot of things. It doesn't necessarily always have to be first. Although, I mean, maybe there's exceptions to that, I guess. But yeah, if you're making a dating app, yeah, whether or not your reliability is 100%, or is, you know, seven nines of uptime
在不同的应用中，比如先发优势的意义是不同的。所以如果你在造一架飞机，它必须是安全的。它需要满足很多条件。它不一定非得是第一个出来的。当然，我的意思是，这可能也有例外吧。但是，是的，如果你在做一个约会软件，那么你的可靠性是不是100%，或者说，你知道的，是不是有七个9的正常运行时间，
and you use the most advanced algorithms for distributed consensus of consistent database updates, yeah, I don't know that anyone cares. Yeah, yeah, exactly. And so, you know, typically here like the the worst case scenario here is where you have someone who just doesn't get that and they want to write just extremely regimented code when you don't have a product or on the flip side um you know that you have a really hacky system it's constantly breaking and you can't really
并且你使用了最先进的算法来实现分布式一致性数据库更新的共识，说实话，我不知道是否有人会在乎。对，对，确实如此。所以，你知道的，通常情况下，这里最糟糕的情况是，你会遇到那种完全不理解这一点的人，当你连产品都还没有的时候，他们就想写出极其刻板的代码；或者反过来，你知道的，你有一个非常拼凑的系统，它不断崩溃，你根本无法
use it as a platform for anything. And people just want to keep hacking on it, right? So those, those are the two extremes. And that's, that's, and so I think you're getting everyone on board with why those are extremes and why there is a better middle ground is the first step. So yeah, another one that you mentioned here is when and how to optimize. What's your take on that? So people love to quote, I think it's a Donald Knuth quote,
把它当作任何东西的平台。而大家只想不断地对它进行粗暴的修改，对吧？所以，这些就是两个极端。这就是，这就是……所以我认为，让每个人都理解为什么这些是极端，以及为什么存在一个更好的折中方案，这是第一步。所以，是的，你在这里提到的另一个问题是，何时以及如何进行优化。你对这个有什么看法？所以人们很喜欢引用，我想这是唐纳德·克努特的一句名言，
is early optimization is the root of all evil. Yeah, go for it. Yeah, okay. Which it's kind of a frustrating quote because I know what he's saying and it's true, but it gets to the heart of this idea of, you know, if you optimize some bit of your code that doesn't end up getting called very often, um, you know, that's not the right place to spend tons of time trying to make the most efficient, you know, selection for how to do your hash mapping hash function um because you only ever end up using it five times the whole time your program runs um and so early optimization really can cause a lot of problems it's true but deciding when to scale or not is and we've talked about this a number of times on the show before but like
那就是“过早优化是万恶之源”。对，尽管说吧。对，好的。这其实是一句让人有点沮丧的名言，因为我知道他在说什么，而且这也是事实，但它切中了这样一个核心概念：你知道的，如果你去优化一小段最终根本没被调用几次的代码，你知道的，那可不是花大量时间去努力为你的哈希映射哈希函数寻找最高效的实现方式的好地方，因为在你的程序运行的整个生命周期中，你总共也就用它五次，所以过早优化确实会导致很多问题，这千真万确；但是决定何时进行扩展与否，我们以前在节目中已经讨论过很多次了，不过就像是
if you sort of say i'm going to go build a web app that scales to 100 people um that's not necessarily a horrible thing or don't even worry about scale because you don't know if it'll be interesting or useful you need to go out and try which is what jason was getting at but at the same time the first time you get featured on uh you know on on reddit front page or you know on hacker news or whatever and your website goes down because you only anticipated getting one user per day and you have it running on, you know, the computer under your desk, you know, that's not ideal either. But building for something that's Facebook scale when you don't even know if anyone cares about your product. Yeah, this is really tough. I guess it's
如果你说“我要去构建一个能够扩展到100人的网络应用”，这倒也不一定是个糟糕的想法；或者甚至根本不用担心扩展问题，因为你不知道它是否有趣或有用，你必须亲自去尝试一下，这正是杰森刚才所表达的意思。但与此同时，当你第一次被推上……你知道的，比如Reddit的头版，或者Hacker News等等，而你的网站因为你只预估了每天一个用户，并且把它跑在你办公桌底下的电脑里而直接崩溃了，你知道的，那也不是什么理想的情况。但是，当连有没有人在乎你的产品都还不知道时，就按照Facebook的规模去进行架构设计，真的太难了。我想这
a little similar to the doing it right before but optimizing means figuring out what parts of the system you're going to choose to design in a way that they you know sort of can scale as well as making sure to try to build enough of a system so that you can start taking measurements about where your performance bottlenecks are but this is something that i find is often comes into a hot debate because the more optimized you make something, you normally don't increase flexibility. You normally make the code harder to read and the systems more tightly coupled as a general rule. And so you introduce a lot of other issues the faster you try to get your processes to go, the more scalable you try to make them. Yeah, that makes sense.
和之前说的“把事情做对”有点类似，但优化意味着你要弄清楚系统的哪些部分，是你选择以某种方式进行设计的，这样它们（你知道的）能够很好地扩展，同时还要确保构建出足够完善的系统，以便你能够开始进行测量，找出性能瓶颈所在。但这是我发现经常引发激烈争论的一个话题，因为你把某样东西优化得越多，通常你就不会增加灵活性。作为一条一般规律，你通常会把代码变得更难读，把系统耦合得更紧密。因此，你试图让你的进程运行得越快，试图让它们越具可扩展性，你就会引入越多其他的问题。是的，这说得通。
I mean, I think if you have this type of argument, so I guess the two positions here that you could be arguing is one is someone wants to optimize something and you don't want them to optimize that. That's probably pretty rare. I mean, unless you're the engine manager and you don't want them to optimize that. That's probably pretty rare. I mean, unless you're the engine manager and you don't want them to optimize it. Well, I mean, I think the issue that comes up here is someone saying, oh, your design, like you should use a different algorithm here. Like, you know, you're doing something naive.
我的意思是，我认为如果你有这种类型的争论，所以我想这里你可能在争论的两种立场是：一种是有人想要优化某些东西，而你不希望他们去优化。那可能相当罕见。我的意思是，除非你是工程经理，而且你不想让他们去优化。那可能相当罕见。我的意思是，除非你是工程经理，而且你不想让他们去优化它。好吧，我的意思是，我认为这里出现的问题是有人说：“哦，你的设计，比如你这里应该用一个不同的算法。你看，你用的方法太天真了。”
Like, oh, you're doing a bubble sort here. Like, why are you doing, okay, that's a bad example. But like, why are you doing merge sort here instead of using, you know, this new research algorithm that says it could potentially go faster, um, when no one really knows the data and you get these, you know, sort of drive by requests often in regards to optimization. Um, you know, like what's going to happen when we have, you know, four orders of magnitude, more data than we have today and it's you know I guess you're right maybe it's a manager to manage employee question that
比如，“哦，你这里在用冒泡排序。你为什么要用……好吧，这是个糟糕的例子。”但是，比如，“你这里为什么不用归并排序，而是要用这种据说可能运行得更快的新研究算法呢？”而当时根本没有人了解数据情况，你经常会收到这种关于优化的“顺便提一句”式的请求。“你知道的，当我们的数据量比今天要多出四个数量级时，会发生什么呢？”而且这……我想你是对的，也许这是一个经理如何管理员工的问题，
comes up a lot but yeah I mean it's it's uh yeah I mean I think I think yeah for it to come from another team that other team probably has because most teams don't necessarily care how optimized other teams codes are unless there it's not an inter team this is yeah i think this would be within your team or a debate between you and your manager yeah exactly because i mean if someone comes to you and says i want to optimize code x then of course you just let them do it unless you're the manager and the issue there is i mean there's there's a bigger issue here which is i guess this ties into the first two questions, is how do you really reward
这种问题经常出现。但是，是的，我的意思是，这……是的，我的意思是，我猜……我猜如果是来自另一个团队，那个团队可能因为大多数团队不一定关心其他团队的代码优化程度，除非这不是一个团队内部的问题——这也是，是的，我认为这会发生在你的团队内部，或者是你和你的经理之间的辩论。对，确实如此，因为如果有人来找你，说“我想优化X代码”，那么你当然会让他们去做，除非你是经理，而这里的问题是——这里有一个更大的问题，我想这与前两个问题息息相关，那就是你到底该如何奖励
that kind of work? And I feel like unless it's releasing a safety valve, you know, so in other words, like you have some critical performance problem and this fixes it, you know, but in all other cases, like if it's even remotely preventative, it's very hard to justify that. And that's one of the reasons why I, it's very hard to justify that. And that's one of the reasons why I think the engineering leadership needs to be technical is so that, you know, those types of work, that type of work could be justified, you know. Yeah. But engineers love tinkering. So, like, I don't know.
这种类型的工作？我觉得除非它是在释放安全阀（你知道的，换句话说，就是你遇到了某个重大的性能问题，而这解决了它），但在所有其他情况下，如果它哪怕有一点点是预防性质的，都很难为此辩护。这也是为什么我认为工程领导层必须具备技术背景的原因之一，这样（你知道的）那种类型的工作、那种性质的工作才能得到合理的辩护。但工程师们就是喜欢瞎折腾。所以，你知道的，我不知道。
I like tinkering. And it's more comfortable to stay in the same code and just keep making it better. Yeah, it makes sense. I won't spend too much time on this, but there's a whole bunch of arguments around languages, which language to use. That's obviously a really big one. One thing to mention there is a lot of people don't know this, but, you know, most big companies use a ton of languages
我喜欢瞎折腾。而且留在同一段代码里不断把它做得更好，会让人感觉更舒适。是的，这说得通。我不会在这上面花太多时间，但是围绕编程语言其实存在着一大堆争论，到底该用哪种语言。这显然是一个非常大的问题。其中有一点需要提及的是，很多人并不知道这一点，但（你知道的）大多数大公司都在使用大量的语言，
and they communicate. They use interprocess communication, they use TCP. And so you have like a Java program talking to a C++ program and things like that. Or if you're getting really sophisticated, you can use Swig or one of these things. But yeah you know you don't have to get like your entire company you know uh revolving around one language by any means um but you know still i mean that's that's going to be a hot debate right there's going to be people who like different languages and uh i think that's a very difficult you know situation um you know i think uh there's obviously a ton of research on whether you should use language X or language Y and people will refer to all of that research. I mean, one of the things to keep in mind here is that it doesn't matter as much as you think it does.
并且它们之间可以进行通信。它们使用进程间通信，使用TCP。所以你会看到一个Java程序在和一个C++程序对话之类的情况。或者如果你追求真正的高端，你可以使用Swig或者其中某类工具。但是，是的，你知道的，你根本不需要让整个公司（你知道的）围绕着某一门语言来运转，这是绝对不需要的；不过，话说回来，这依然会是一场激烈的辩论，对吧？会有一些人喜欢不同的语言，而我认为这是一个非常困难（你知道的）的局面。你知道的，我认为（显然）有很多关于你究竟该使用X语言还是Y语言的研究，人们会参考所有这些研究。我的意思是，这里需要记住的一点是，它并没有你想象的那么重要。
I mean, I've written PHP, I've written all sorts of languages that and hopefully this show kind of really conveys that message to people. If you've been following our show, then you already kind of know this um but you know if at the end of the day someone you know really wants to use language x and for whatever reason you know or let's just make it more obvious the whole company except you wants to use language x then uh it's it's actually not the end of the world it's not too bad. It always seems worse than it is, you know, using a language that is not preferred. But I mean, it's a real issue. It's very difficult.
我的意思是，我写过PHP，我写过各种各样的语言，希望这个节目真的能把这个信息传达给听众。如果你一直关注我们的节目，那你其实就已经知道了这一点。但是，你知道的，如果到了最后，有人（你知道的）真的非常想用X语言，不管出于什么原因（或者让我们说得更明显一点，除了你之外的整个公司都想用X语言），那么……其实这也不是世界末日，也没有那么糟糕。使用一门非首选的语言，感觉总是比实际情况要糟糕。但我的意思是，这是一个真实存在的问题。这非常困难。
I mean, we actually had this today. At work, we decided to rewrite something in another language. And so we built a prototype and it had a lot of the nice features that we liked specifically so we're porting stuff that was written in sql to a real programming language that has unit tests and things like that um and so you know we kind of agreed we had a round table we agreed that is a way to go um but i think part of the reason why we agreed is that we had been through so much pain
我的意思是，我们今天实际上就遇到了这种情况。在工作时，我们决定用另一种语言重写某个东西。所以我们构建了一个原型，它具有很多我们喜欢的优秀特性，具体来说，就是我们要把用SQL编写的东西移植到一个真正的、带有单元测试等特性的编程语言中。所以，你知道的，我们算是达成了一致，我们开了一个圆桌会议，一致认为这就是前进的方向。但我认为我们之所以达成一致，部分原因是我们经历过太多的痛苦，
uh you know with the original approach um so you know if someone was brand new on the team they might not see the reason for for doing that um but yeah in general this i would say this is also in the camp of really really difficult arguments um like what would you do patrick if someone said we need to rewrite our whole thing and i don't know some other language yeah i mean i'm a big fan of the right tool for the right job. But I guess your contention that it doesn't matter as much as you think depends a lot on the situation. So if you're writing, you know, code that's distributed via inter-process communication and you want to write in a language that works fine via that mechanism, then yeah, probably
（你知道的）伴随着最初的那种方法。所以，如果团队里来了一个新人，他可能不会明白为什么要这样做。但是，是的，总的来说，我可以说这也是属于“极度困难的争论”这一阵营的。比如，帕特里克，如果有人说“我们需要用别的什么语言把整个系统全部重写一遍”，你会怎么做？是的，我的意思是，我非常支持“用正确的工具做正确的事情”。但我猜你关于“它没有你想象的那么重要”的论断，在很大程度上取决于具体情况。所以如果你编写的代码（你知道的）是通过进程间通信分发的，并且你想用一种能通过这种机制正常工作的语言来编写，那么，是的，可能
not a big deal. If you're writing a library that needs to be performance oriented that other people are going to call, you probably want it, or you're going to have to sign up to maintaining wrappers into the language that everybody uses. So if you're working at a video game studio and someone needs a bullet physics library, you're not going to be writing that in Java. Yeah, that makes sense. So sometimes it matters. library, you're not going to be writing that in Java. Yeah, that makes sense. So sometimes it matters.
就不是什么大问题。如果你正在编写一个需要面向性能、且会被其他人调用的库，你可能就会希望……或者你将不得不承诺去维护能够转换到每个人都在使用的语言的包装器。因此，如果你在一家电子游戏工作室工作，有人需要一个子弹物理库，你总不能用Java来写那个库吧。是的，这说得通。所以有时它确实很重要。库，你总不能用Java来写那个库吧。是的，这说得通。所以有时它确实很重要。
And if you're writing a script that's just a one-off, like I mostly care about the data product, again, probably doesn't matter. And for me, though, for code that is going to be needing to be maintained and sort of stable in production and known and code reviewed, you need to have at least some body of knowledge, you know, on your team or commitment from everybody that they are okay with that language choice. So if somebody decides, you know, I'm going to go write this widget in, you know, language foo, and nobody else really is interested or wants to do it, you end up with
如果你写的是一个一次性的脚本，比如我主要只关心数据产品，同样地，这可能也不重要。但是对我而言，对于那些需要进行维护、在生产环境中保持稳定、需要为人所知并经过代码审查的代码，你的团队中必须具备至少一定的主体知识，（你知道的）或者需要得到每个人的承诺，即他们都同意这种语言的选择。所以如果有人决定（你知道的）：“我要用（你知道的）foo语言来写这个小部件”，而其他所有人其实都没有兴趣或者不想这么做，你最终就会陷入
this problem, which I see happen sometimes, where that person goes and writes that tool and then later they leave the team and then you need to go use that tool and it's always everybody dreads it because it's like oh it's written in foo and nobody knows how to go in and fix it or and it breaks all the time and you end up with this problem of like you've saddled that team with something they didn't really want yeah that's a really good point actually if you want, if you want to be passive aggressive at work as a software engineer, probably the most passive aggressive thing you can do, like that's the most destructive, is to write something in a very obscure language. We had someone write, we had this system, and like Patrick says, is meant to hook into
这样一个问题——我有时会看到这种情况发生：那个人去写了那个工具，然后后来他离开了团队，而你需要去使用那个工具，每个人都对它感到畏惧，因为感觉就像是“噢，它是用foo写的，没有人知道该怎么进去修复它”，或者它总是崩溃，而你最终会陷入这样的困境：你给那个团队套上了一个他们根本不想要的负担。是的，这真是一个很好的观点。实际上，如果你想在工作中表现得消极抵抗（作为一名软件 engineer），你可能能做出的最消极抵抗、最具破坏性的事情，就是用一门非常晦涩难懂的语言来写东西。我们以前有人写过……我们有这样一个系统，正如帕特里克所说的那样，它是为了与……
not necessarily hook in but it's meant to it was meant as a library where people would would uh many people would add their own flavor to it right so think of it as sort of an sdk like open gl or something and you would the plan was to build something in open gl or in this case in this library in this sdk And the person wrote it in Haskell. And the issue there was, you know, now anyone who wanted to use our system had to learn this language. And so, you know, in the context of many alternatives, most people just said, well, I'm not going to learn a whole language when I could just use some alternate system that gets me, let's say, 90% of the way there,
不一定是挂钩，但它的本意是一个库，人们可以在其中……许多人会往里面添加他们自己的特色，对吧？所以你可以把它想象成某种SDK，比如OpenGL之类的，然后你……我们的计划是用OpenGL构建一些东西，或者在本例中，是在这个库、这个SDK中构建。而那个人是用Haskell编写的。这里的问题在于，现在任何想要使用我们系统的人都必须学习这门语言。所以，你知道的，在有许多替代选择的情况下，大多数人只会说：“好吧，既然我可以只用某种能让我达到比如90%目标的替代系统，
but, you know, I can write it in Python. And so that person, after spending over a year writing the SDK, had to completely rewrite it in Python. And that was extremely painful. So, yeah, I think it's a really good point is you have to really look at your audience. And, you know, if you're at a company where everyone's writing in Haskell, then, you know, you really need to think about that before you make an argument. Like, unless, I mean, like, as Patrick said, like, if you have to do a physics engine, you're not going to do that. Actually, I don't know how fast Haskell is.
而且（你知道的）我可以用Python来写，那我就没必要去学整门语言了。”因此，那个人在花了一年多时间编写这个SDK之后，不得不完全用Python将其重写。这极其痛苦。所以，是的，我认为这是一个非常好的观点，你必须真正审视你的受众。而且，你知道的，如果你在一家每个人都在用Haskell编写代码的公司里，那么（你知道的）在你提出论点之前，你真的需要好好考虑这一点。除非——我的意思是，就像帕特里克说的，如果你必须做一个物理引擎，你总不会用那个去写。事实上，我不知道Haskell有多快。
Let's say, I don't know, basic or something. I don't know. Python. You're not going to write like a physics engine in pure Python. But, you know, I mean, once you get rid of the kind of very obvious constraints, right, you should think really carefully before you do anything other than the, you know, most common language that your team or your organization is using, right? I mean, just don't underestimate, like try like try to really avoid having that argument you know and on the flip side if someone you know if 90 of your code base is python and someone wants to write something in erlang um you know i mean there there needs to be like a
比方说，我不知道，比如Basic之类的。我不知道。Python。你总不能用纯Python来写一个物理引擎吧。但是，你知道的，一旦你抛开那些非常明显的限制，对吧？在你做任何不属于你的团队或组织正在使用的最常见语言的事情之前，你都应该非常仔细地思考，对吧？我的意思是，千万不要低估……尽量真的去避免引发那场争论。而反过来，如果有人（你知道的）——如果你们90%的代码库都是Python，而有人想用Erlang来写点东西，（你知道的）那你们必须得有一个
really solid reason for that and sometimes there are but then i think what jason describes the right way i think you build a little prototype you try to shop it around to the team and you know say like hey i went and did this thing like look at advantage x y and z you know that this is really going to be a game changer for us yep yeah exactly like there has to be real tangible benefits yeah yeah so tabs versus spaces we brought this up and got emails about this from people so people are very passionate actually it's in the in the silicon valley show tabs versus spaces yeah um this is a debate just avoid it style you should have style guidelines uh and you know you should i i'm a big fan of like
非常坚实的理由才行。有时确实会有这样的理由，但随后我认为杰森描述的方法才是正确的方式：我想你可以构建一个小原型，试着把它推销给团队，（你知道的）然后说：“嘿，我做了这个东西，来看看X、Y、Z的好处吧，你知道的，这真的会成为我们的游戏规则改变者。”对，对，确实如此，这必须带来真正切实的利益。对，对……所以，关于制表符（Tabs）与空格（Spaces），我们之前提过这个，并且收到了人们发来的相关邮件，所以大家对此其实非常热情。实际上《硅谷》这部剧里也有制表符对空格的桥段。对，这是一个争论，干脆避开它。风格上，你们应该制定风格指南，并且（你知道的）我非常喜欢
pick something and stick to it and new people come to the team they don't like them they don't want them it's it sucks it's a struggle but everyone come to the team. They don't like them. They don't want them. It's, it sucks. It's a struggle, but everyone needs to have, you don't have to make them overly restrictive, but you need some guidance on not writing bad code. And if you don't have it written down, everybody's going to argue about it,
选定某种风格并坚持下去。如果有新人加入团队，他们不喜欢，他们不想要，这真的很糟，这是一场挣扎，但每个人来到团队——他们不喜欢，他们不想要，这真的很糟，这是一场挣扎，但每个人都需要拥有……你不需要把它们搞得过于具有限制性，但你确实需要一些关于不要编写糟糕代码的指导原则。如果你没有把它写下来，每个人都会在
every code review. So it's better to write it down and like just hash it out. And hopefully your manager is technical enough to just come in and make a consensus decree yeah i mean i don't know if if this is just a benefit of python or if this is the way the team works but the team i'm on now this the um they have a very complicated um automatic style like a prettier um and the cool thing is basically the the team philosophy is if the automatic system whatever it does is is the truth so in other words like if you can write now you can obviously like you know uh you could write like really obscure obfuscated code and and you
每一次代码审查中为此争论不休。所以最好把它写下来，然后彻底讨论清楚。希望你们的经理具备足够的技术背景，能够直接介入并做出达成共识的裁决。是的，我不知道——如果这仅仅是Python的好处，还是团队工作方式的好处，但我现在所在的这个团队，他们拥有一套非常复杂的自动风格工具，就像Prettier一样。而最酷的地方在于，基本上团队的哲学就是：这个自动系统无论做什么，它就是真理。换句话说，如果你现在能写……你显然可以（你知道的）写出非常晦涩、经过混淆的代码，并且你可以
could trick the the prettier right but uh you know no one's really done that yet hasn't really come up even once and then basically yeah the prettier is so sophisticated that people just they write code however they want and then once they run this it's like an auto formatter exactly yeah yeah it just automatically you know adheres to a certain style and um yeah i really like that i I mean, I honestly, I used to really hate getting style feedback on my changes. And I think the reason why is I always felt like, you know, it made me feel like just like this cog in the machine. It's like, oh, you know, this should be, you know, indented a little bit more or something.
欺骗Prettier，对吧？但是（你知道的）还没有人真正那样做过，甚至连一次都没发生过。基本上，是的，Prettier是如此复杂，以至于大家想怎么写代码就怎么写，一旦他们运行了这个工具——这就像是一个自动格式化工具。对，完全正确。它只是会自动（你知道的）遵循某种特定的风格。而且，是的，我真的很喜欢这样。说实话，我以前真的很讨厌在我的修改意见中收到关于风格的反馈。我想原因在于，我总是觉得（你知道的）这让我觉得自己只是机器里的一个齿轮。感觉就像是，“噢，（你知道的）这里应该再多缩进一点之类的。”
And that kind of went away when i like clang format or uh you know the pie flake eight or whatever when these things came out that basically just did all of this for us it's like i mean in your case do you do you ever have to actually do this style manually like what kind of decisions you know but i mean somebody has to decide which of like you know i read a lot of c++ code like there are many different c++ style guidelines like should should you put a space before and after a plus operator you know the big one that always comes up is where should the pointer the asterisk go should it go on the variable should it go on the type should it go with the space on both sides it's got to go on the type right no it definitely should go on the variable we should it go on the type? Should it go with the space on both sides? It's got to go on the type, right?
而当Clang Format或者（你知道的）PyFlake8之类的好东西问世、基本上为我们搞定这一切之后，那种感觉就消失了。这就好比——在你这种情况下，你是否曾经不得不真正手动处理这种风格问题？比如你会做出什么样的决定？（你知道的）但我的意思是，总得有人来决定……比如我读了大量的C++代码，C++有许多不同的风格指南——你是否应该在加号运算符的前后各加一个空格？你知道的，一直以来讨论最多的一个大问题是：指针（星号）应该放在哪里？它应该放在变量名上？还是应该放在类型上？它应该带有一个两边都有空格的位置吗？它肯定得放在类型上吧？不对，它绝对应该放在变量上。我们可别在这个问题上纠结。等等，等等。不，停，停，停。我们完全会被带沟里的。我们会证明这个观点。你可以创造……对于这两种方式，其实都有合理的论据。所以它最终归结为一种观点。
No, it definitely should go on the variable. We're not getting on this. Hang on, hang on. No, stop, stop, stop. We will completely derail. We'll prove this point. You can create, there are legitimate arguments for both. So it ultimately just comes down to an opinion.
并没有什么合乎逻辑的、显而易见的东西。嗯，我一直觉得指针才是那个改变类型的东西。但你可以在单行上声明多个指针，所以如果你写类似“int star a comma b”的代码，b就不会是一个指针类型。噢，好吧，确实如此，是的。所以它并不是以那种方式修改类型的，这说得通，我从来没想过这一点。是的，我的意思是，这是我能给出的最简练的例子了。还有其他更微妙的……好吧，我们不会在这个问题上扯远了……（你知道的）有很多风格指南，我认为这是一个经常爆发的争论。当你加入一个新团队，而他们要么没有风格指南，要么拥有一套你并不赞同的风格时，
There isn't a logical, obvious. Well, I always felt like the pointer is what changes the type. But you can put multiple on a single line so if you do like int star a comma b b wouldn't be a pointer type oh well that's true yeah so then it's not it's not modifying the type in that way that makes sense i never thought about that yeah i mean that's the most succinct one i can give there's other more nuanced right okay we're not going to get off on this um the you know lots of style guidelines and i think this is an argument that gets had and this is one of the things where when you join a new team and they either don't have a style or they have a style you disagree
这真的是一个非常艰难的处境，你真的必须权衡你的选项，想想你究竟该怎么做。所以如果根本没有风格指南——我曾遇到过这样的情况：我加入了一个团队，他们确实没有一致的风格。他们并没有真正严格遵守。而我加入之后，（你知道的）成了那个开始强制推行风格的人。这消耗了我作为团队新人的大量好感，因为我来到这里，而我的老板（可以说是）告诉我“这就是我希望你做的”，然后我不得不去告诉别人：“是的，你们过去两年里写代码的方式很糟糕，很混乱，看起来不好看。”所以，如果你加入一个团队，而他们有风格指南，
with it's a really tough situation you really got to weigh your options about what are you going to do so if there's no style i was in an instance where I joined a team, didn't really have a consistent style. They weren't really adhered to it. And I came in and, you know, sort of was the one who began enforcing the style. And it took a lot of goodwill out of my sale from being the new person on the team to coming in and having my boss sort of tell me that, yeah, that's what I want you to do. And, you know, have to go in and tell people, yeah, the way you've been writing code for the last two years is bad and it's confusing and doesn't look good. Um, and so if you go on a team and they have a style guideline,
那就好办多了。
I would say, try to go with it for some period of time and try to, if there's really things you think don't make sense or are inconsistent or aren't great, like try to work on them like as small things, um, as opposed to just coming in and like erupting with this sucks. This is a completely wrong. You guys are horrible. Don't do that. Yeah. That makes sense. I think, you know, like any, you know, uh, I guess artists, right. I mean, you can think of it as an art, uh, you know, there's a stereotypical, like the artist is super self-critical and critical of the medium and things like that. And it's easy for people to be that way. And so it's really important. I think the overarching lesson, if I could say one thing, is that it's really important to step back and say, okay, take myself out of the equation.
我会说，试着去适应一段时间，如果有你觉得真的说不通、不一致或者不太好的地方，试着去从小处着手解决它们，嗯，而不是一上来就爆发说这太烂了，这完全是错的，你们太糟糕了，别这么做。是的，这说得通。我想，你知道，就像任何，你知道，嗯，我猜艺术家一样，对吧？我的意思是，你可以把它当作一种艺术，嗯，你知道，有一种刻板印象，就是艺术家对自己超级苛刻，对媒介和诸如此类的东西也很苛刻。人们很容易陷入这种状态。所以这真的很重要。我想，如果我只能说一句话的话，最重要的宏观教训就是，退后一步说，好吧，把自己排除在外的做法真的很重要。
And think about, is this really that big a deal? So, yeah, another thing is, you know, IDEs or text editors. This is less of an issue now that there is, you know, automatic styling. Because a lot of the, there might be some people who, you know, where the IDE is actually carrying a lot of weight. Like you have the build system integrated with the IDE. Yeah, this depends a lot on the the project whether this is a personal choice or a team choice yeah if you're building an iOS app or something for example you might be well there you might not have a choice at all so there's not really an argument but in some cases like you said
然后思考，这真的是一件大事吗？所以，是的，另一件事是，你知道，IDE或文本编辑器。现在有了自动代码风格格式化工具，这个问题就没那么严重了。因为很多，可能会有一些人，你知道，他们的IDE其实承担了很重的分量。比如你把构建系统和IDE集成在一起。是的，这很大程度上取决于项目，这究竟是个人选择还是团队选择。是的，如果你在开发一个iOS应用或者类似的东西，那么你可能，好吧，在那里你可能根本没得选，所以其实没什么好争论的。但在某些情况下，就像你说的
if there's like a plugin that needs to be hooked into a custom build system or something and if your team is creating or maintaining that plugin and whether you maintain it for IDE A or B or sometimes like for people will be really into Emacs and have a complex set of Emacs plugins uh yeah that's right and uh you know they share that around the team and everybody uses it and if you're trying to use VI yeah that's anyways yeah yeah I mean this is more I think this is mostly a personal opinion like oops right over time oh no i was just gonna say like yeah this this this argument is pretty rare especially nowadays that the ide like before you know
如果有什么插件需要挂载到一个自定义的构建系统或者类似的东西上，而且如果你们团队正在创建或维护那个插件，不管你是为IDE A还是IDE B维护它，或者有时候有些人会非常沉迷于Emacs并且有一套复杂的Emacs插件，嗯，是的，没错，而且，你知道，他们会在团队里分享这个，每个人都在用，如果你想用VI，嗯，不管怎样，是的，是的，我的意思是，这更多，我想这主要是个人的看法，就像哎呀，随着时间的推移，哦不，我本来想说的是，是的，这个，这个，这个争论其实挺少见的，尤其是现在，IDE就像以前一样，你知道
like visual studio would also be your build system um now people don't really do that anymore and and so especially now if you want to do continuous integration or something like that you need to have a build system that's sort of orthogonal to your, or separate from your editor. And so, yeah, I mean, at most jobs, you should be able to use whatever ID you want. So I guess the only argument would be, you know, like how much work is it going to take and maintenance is it going to take to let you use the editor you want? And, you know, will everyone around you, so you might be in a position where you need everyone around you to make, let's say, a small sacrifice, like, for example, learning make so that you don't have to be forced to use Visual Studio, for example. And I think this is actually I would echo Patrick's advice from earlier that basically you don't come in on day one and say, everyone, we're going to switch to make. So you're going to have to bite the bullet and do some Visual Studio, at least in the beginning. But one thing that would be good is,
比如Visual Studio也会成为你的构建系统，现在人们不再真的那样做了，所以特别是现在，如果你想做持续集成或者类似的事情，你需要有一个独立于你的编辑器，或者说与你的编辑器正交的构建系统。所以，是的，我的意思是，在大多数工作中，你应该能够使用你想要的任何IDE。所以我想唯一的争论会是，你知道，比如让你使用你想要的编辑器会需要付出多少工作量和维护成本？而且，你知道，你周围的每个人，所以你可能会处于这样一种境地：你需要周围的每个人都做一点小小的牺牲，比如，学习使用make，这样你就不用被迫使用Visual Studio了。我认为这实际上，我会呼吁帕特里克早些时候的建议，基本上就是你不要在第一天就走进来宣布：大家注意，我们要切换到make。所以你必须咬紧牙关，至少在开始时用一段时间Visual Studio。但有一件好事是，
you know, take the initiative to, you know, redo your entire build system and make, present that to the team and say, look, we have something, you know, I can run it on in the cloud, has all these advantages. You know, also I also be able to use any editor I want. But they kind of show up, show up with a solution. I think that makes a really big difference. Now, that's going to take a lot of energy and it might be wasted. But I mean, if you're that passionate about, you know, using Emacs, for example, then that, that, that's, um, that's a risk you want to take, right? So, so showing up with a solution is always, um, a way, way better. Um, even if you
你知道，主动去重构你的整个构建系统并使用make，把它呈献给团队并说，看，我们有这样一个方案，你知道，我可以在云端运行它，它有所有这些优点。你知道，我也能使用任何我想要的编辑器了。但这有点像是带着解决方案出现。我认为这会产生很大的不同。当然，这会消耗大量精力，而且可能白费。但我的意思是，如果你对使用Emacs这件事如此充满热情，那么，那，那，嗯，那是一个你愿意承担的风险，对吧？所以，带着解决方案出现永远是，嗯，一种好得多，好得多的方法。嗯，甚至如果你
have to sort of do it, you know, on your own time, um, you know, like, like, you know, on the, if you have to come into work on a weekend or something to do it, it might be worth it because, because it could, you know, kind of pivot the whole team then so we're running quite a bit long but uh let's talk a little bit about how if you do get yourself into one of these arguments some uh some good guidelines to stand by yeah that makes sense i mean i think uh we covered a lot of it but just to summarize um you know really you know and be honest with yourself and really reflect on why you want what you want. There are some people who you could see them, they show up on day one, they're like, oh, everything has to be written in Scala or something like that. And really think about what do you, and be honest with yourself.
不得不以某种方式在自己的时间里完成它，嗯，你知道，就像，你知道，如果在周末不得不来公司加班或者做点什么来完成它，那也许也是值得的，因为，因为这可能会，你知道，从而扭转整个团队的方向。所以我们超时了不少，不过，嗯，让我们稍微聊聊，如果你真的陷入了其中一场争论，有什么，嗯，一些值得坚持的好准则。是的，这说得通，我的意思是，我想，嗯，我们已经涵盖了很多，但总的来说，嗯，你知道，真的，你知道，对自己诚实，并认真反思为什么你想要你所想要的东西。有些人，你能看到他们，第一天来就说，哦，所有东西都必须用Scala重写或者诸如此类的话。要真正思考你到底想要什么，并对自己诚实。
For example, maybe you want to use Scala because you want to learn Scala. Maybe you want to use scala because you want to learn scala maybe you want to learn scala it's a skill for you and you have a chance to learn it um while you're working so basically like learn it for free like on someone else's dime and and now have be more marketable right but i mean that could that's fine you know but but and you obviously you have to you know speak with some tact and you know, just go into the meeting saying, hey, I want to learn a new language on your dime, boss. But but beyond but, you know, internally, be honest with yourself. Right. So know what your values are, why you want the things you do and have clarity there. Also, you know, think about the compromises or the alternatives. Right. Like what is alternative?
比如，也许你想用Scala是因为你想学Scala。也许你想学Scala对你来说是一项技能，你工作时有机会去学它，嗯，基本上就像免费学一样，花着别人的钱，然后现在变得更有市场价值了，对吧？但我的意思是，这也可以，你知道的，但但是，你显然得表现得有些策略，你知道的，走进会议室就说，嘿，老板，我想花你的钱学门新语言。不过但除此之外，你知道的，内心要对自己诚实。对。所以要清楚自己的价值观是什么，为什么想要那些东西，并在那里保持清晰。还有，你知道的，想想妥协或替代方案。对。比如替代方案是什么？
What are you going to lose? And that's going to really tell you how much energy you need to spend or risk, let's say, on getting the change you want, right? So this gets back to the whole building the prototype and make, right? Like if coding in Visual Studio is so frustrating to you that you're going to lose a lot of productivity and it's going to frustrate you, it's going to make you not like this job,
你要失去什么？这将真正告诉你，为了得到你想要的改变，你需要花多少精力或承担多少风险，对吧？所以这又回到了构建原型并进行制作的整个过程，对吧？比如，如果在Visual Studio里编码让你如此沮丧，以至于你会失去很多生产力，并且会让你感到沮丧，让你不喜欢这份工作，
then it's worth spending an extra 40 hours off the clock porting the whole thing to make and trying to convince everyone to do that, right? If you think about it, then you might think, oh, it's not that big a deal. I'll just bite the bullet and do Visual Studio studio right but but figure that out kind of beforehand um and the second part of that is is you know when you have this argument and the argument could be impromptu where you don't really have time to figure it out right but whether you've had time or not um don't necessarily like force a decision right away. Like this isn't, you know, like a criminal
那么花额外的40个小时下班时间把整个东西移植到Mac上并试图说服每个人都这么做是值得的，对吧？如果你仔细想想，你可能会觉得，哦，没那么大不了。我还是咬咬牙用Visual Studio吧，但但是要在事前弄清楚这一点，嗯，第二部分是，你知道的，当你进行这场争论时，这场争论可能是即兴的，你并没有真正的时间去弄清楚它，对吧？所以不管你有没有时间，嗯，不一定要马上强行做出决定。这可不是，你知道的，什么刑事
trial or something, right? So, you know, have a discussion about it, try to keep things open-ended, at least initially, you know, go home, think about what was said, think about how that might change, you know, the state and the compromises you have to make, and then show up the next day sort of with the next sort of evolution of this argument, right? And, you know, kind of slowly converge to a solution that's often way better than, and if you have that expectation
审判之类的，对吧？所以，你知道的，讨论一下，尽量保持开放的结局，至少最初是这样，你知道的，回家想想大家说了什么，想想这可能会如何改变，你知道的，现状以及你不得不做出的妥协，然后第二天带着对这场争论的下一步演变出现，对吧？然后，你知道的，慢慢收敛到一个解决方案，通常比如果你抱有那种期望要好得多
that this is a convergence process and not like a jury, that's really going to sort of change the attitude and you could actually, you could lose the argument and have to use Visual Studio to extend the example, but actually gain a lot of respect based on sort of how you handle yourself in that situation. Yeah, I think that's one we don't have on here, but picking your battles, even though technically, right, you might be correct
即这是一个收敛过程而不是像陪审团审判那样的期望，这真的会改变态度，而且你实际上可能会输掉争论，不得不使用Visual Studio来延伸这个例子，但实际上由于你在那种情况下处理自己的方式而赢得了极大的尊重。是的，我觉得这是我们这里没有提到的一点，但要挑选你的战斗，尽管从技术上讲，对吧，你可能在所有这些事情上都是正确的
across all of these things. People are, you're not going to be a very popular person if you're fighting everybody on every front all the time yep yeah there's this saying like uh you know don't be dead wrong but don't be dead right right so so i think that the metaphor that they use is you know you're driving on the highway uh you know some like country highway two-lane highway and a semi is coming the other way, they're driving on the wrong side of the road, right? You don't just like hit the semi head on just on principle, you know? And so it's the same thing here where, you know, at the end of the day, like part of this is just respecting other people's values. And so if the whole team has one set of values,'s the semi right and and
在所有这些事情上。人们，如果你一直与所有人在各个方面争吵，你不会是一个很受欢迎的人，对吧？是的，有这样一句俗语，比如，嗯，你知道，不要死错，但也别死对，对吧？所以所以我觉得他们用的比喻是，你知道你在高速公路上开车，嗯，比如某种乡间高速公路，双车道高速公路，一辆半挂卡车迎面开来，他们在路的错误一侧开车，对吧？你不会仅仅因为原则问题就和半挂卡车迎头相撞，对吧？所以这里也是一样，你知道，归根结底，这的一部分只是尊重别人的价值观。所以如果整个团队都有一套价值观，那辆卡车就是对的，而且
and whether they're right or not you're gonna have to handle that situation sort of very delicately and other thing i'm know i struggle with sometimes is be careful to pay attention to other people's demeanor their feelings even if you're having a technical argument some people become passionate and are okay having a heated debate and other people begin to have a very personal reaction and don't necessarily take well to having their choices questioned or something. Even if you're well-intentioned, even if you don't mean it that way, but you know, do it. And also the venue for having these discussions you know if you have a weekly whole team meeting some people might be fine discussing stuff in that other people might
不管他们对不对，你都得非常小心地处理那种情况。我有时还要纠结的另一件事是，要注意别人的态度、他们的感受，即使你在进行一场技术争论。有些人会变得充满激情，愿意进行激烈的辩论，而另一些人则会开始产生非常个人化的反应，不一定能很好地接受他们的选择受到质疑之类的事情。即使你是出于好意，即使你不是那个意思，但你知道，要注意。还有进行这些讨论的场所，你知道，如果你每周开一次全团队会议，有些人可能觉得在那种场合讨论事情很好，而另一些人可能
rather you talk to them at their desk or schedule a special meeting or have this discussion over email where they can think about their responses um and be slight you know be sensitive as you can to how other people prefer to have these exchanges. Yeah, that totally makes sense. But definitely always do them loudly in the middle of your building. Like that's the like definite goal. Yeah, that's right. Oh man, we actually just decided we moved
更愿意你在他们的办公桌前和他们谈谈，或者安排一次专门的会议，或者通过电子邮件进行讨论，这样他们可以思考自己的回应，嗯，并且对其他人更敏感，尽可能地顺应别人喜欢如何进行这些交流。是的，这完全说得通。但绝对要一直在你们大楼中央大声地进行。这绝对是最终目标。是的，没错。哦天哪，我们实际上刚刚决定搬家
and the new desk area, we got there, we're like, this is amazing. We're all super excited. And it's even a new building so we don't really have any bearings um we're so unbelievably excited and then we realized that we sit right over the the restaurant a restaurant and uh around noon it's just like a total madhouse you can't hear anything and i never realized it's the first time i've really been in this position.
到了新的办公区域，我们一到那儿就想，这太棒了。我们都超级兴奋。甚至是一栋新建筑，所以我们基本上没有什么方向感，我们兴奋得无以复加，然后我们意识到我们的座位正好在那个餐馆，一家餐馆的上面，然后呢，大约中午时分，这里简直就像个疯人院，你什么也听不见，我以前从未意识到，这是我第一次真正处于这种位置。
But, yeah, noise pollution is, like, actually a huge problem. But, yeah, so don't have your big arguments in the middle of the room. Also, as I said before, like, you know, converge slowly. You know, there's very few things you actually need to rush. Yeah, you don't, like, need to decide whether you're going to rewrite the whole thing in Java today. That almost never needs to happen. And so, as Patrick said, some people, I mean, it might be a combination of shyness, but it also might be some people just, they don't have, they just need to think about things, right? And everyone, you know, when they sleep on things, they come back with sort of a slightly different perspective right and so you want to take
但是，是的，噪音污染其实是一个大问题。不过，是的，所以不要把你们的大争论放在房间中央。另外，正如我之前所说，你知道，慢慢收敛。你知道，实际上很少有事情你需要急于求成。是的，你不需要，比如，今天就决定是否要用Java重写整个东西。那几乎从来不需要发生。所以，正如帕特里克所说，有些人，我的意思是，这可能是害羞的组合，但也可能是有些人只是，他们没有，他们只是需要思考事情，对吧？每个人，你知道，当他们把事情放过夜再想时，他们回来时会有稍微不同的视角，对吧，所以你想利用
advantage of of of that latent perspective or push for your victory yeah you know yeah if you have the majority that just try to close the deal right away i'm sorry it's like buying a used car or something um cool well yeah let us know i'm really curious to think uh to hear what you think about this episode um you folks out there um you know we this is i would say this is like a completely different uh you know style of of episode for us because this is just very ad hoc um we're really just kind of relaying like life experiences and let us know what you think. So, you know, we have the interview format. We have the something where it's like a very specific subject format, like machine learning or C++ or something like that. This is almost like a,
利用那种潜在的视角，或者推动你的胜利。是的，你知道，是的，如果你占多数，就马上试着敲定交易，对吧？抱歉，这就像买二手车什么的。酷，好吧，是的，让我们知道，我真的很想听听你对这一集的看法，大家，你知道的，我们，我会说这是一个完全不同的，你知道的，对我们来说风格的一集，因为这非常即兴，我们真的只是在转述生活经验，让我们知道你们的想法。所以，你知道，我们有访谈形式。我们有某种非常特定主题的形式，比如机器学习或C++之类的。这几乎就像一个，
I look at this as almost like a third format. And so I'm really curious, this is sort of us dipping our toe in this. Let us know what you think, if this was interesting to you. You're based on the time we can clearly talk about this forever. So that part was good. But let us know if you found it entertaining. Till next time. See you later. The intro music is Axo by Vynar Pilot.
我觉得这几乎就像第三种形式。所以我很好奇，这是我们在这方面的初次尝试。让我们知道你们的想法，这是否对你们有趣。根据时间，我们显然可以永远谈论这个。所以那部分很好。但让我们知道你们是否觉得它有趣。下次见。再见。片头曲是Vynar Pilot的《Axo》。
Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share-A-Like 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Programming Throwdown 在知识共享 署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可证下发布。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音、改编作品，但您必须向我和帕特里克提供署名，并以相同方式分享。本集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。